That's why you have a producer,
jamie is on the ball.
Talk a little closer to the light.
Yeah,
get that sucker right up to you.
Just pull it.
You need to move it around.
Bring it to you.
You don't want to feel uncomfortable.
These chairs that shit on it.
Well,
I've.
Oh,
we're live,
live,
live.
Oh,
uh,
I'm here with my good pal.
Ryan Callahan.
How are you buddy?
I'm doing swell.
How are you doing his good pal.
Ken Kruth met you before at the first
light booth at the shot.
Show those the first time I met you,
right?
I think so.
I think that's it.
Yeah.
And we wanted to have you guys on,
first of all because I like,
I love your company.
You guys got a great company.
Firstlight makes really cool hunting
clothes,
outdoor clothes made out of you.
Started out with Merino wool,
which I think uh,
before I went with Ryan and Steven
Rinella,
I really had no idea about the
properties of Merino wool.
I didn't know that it keeps you from
stinking that it,
that it really retains heat while you're
wet.
So it's got so many awesome properties
to it,
like if you go out for people that don't
know,
that don't go in the outdoors,
but if you go out and you walk and it's
cold out and you hike like a long
distance and you get sweaty,
if you're wearing cotton,
you're kind of fucked.
If it's really cold out,
once you start getting sweaty,
your body starts shivering and you get
in a real bad place.
We'll has this really weird quality and
maybe you can help me explain that
where,
when it gets wet,
it somehow or another still retains
heat.
So if you sweat in it,
you still feel okay,
I kinda know what's going on there.
Well,
it,
you know,
it just naturally moves the sweat off of
your skin and kind of tries to get it to
the outermost layer and at which point
then it can evaporate fast.
But,
um,
you know,
she passed to live in crazy
environments,
you know,
it'll be hotter than shit in the
summertime and then,
um,
you know,
super cold in the winter.
So,
you know,
over the course of evolution,
they've got,
you know,
a coat that will deal with a massive
amount of variance,
you know,
and will was pretty much the same.
It's like you can wear it when it's,
when you're sweating,
bullets at pulls a sweat off and then,
um,
dries pretty quickly,
but even when it's wet it pretends to 80
percent of its heat.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
It's amazing stuff.
And is there a synthetic material that
does the same thing?
Well,
every synthetic is trying to a mimic
down or be mimicked Merino wool because
those are the two most efficient,
um,
you know,
temperature,
regulating fabrics or materials out
there.
Um,
and that's,
that's how you got into your prima lofts
and your all,
your military testing and that's where
you saw synthetics really take off.
Um,
so yeah,
so like a prima law for example,
or some of your fleeces,
they basically,
um,
combined something that loves water and
something that hates water.
So the thing that love loves water is
going to pull moisture off and the thing
that hates it is going to repel it and
try to push it to the outside.
That's interesting.
So it's like sort of a two layer process
where something's trying to keep you dry
and something is trying to like
literally suck up the wet,
like a sponge and then somehow or
another your body heat then can regulate
it because your body heat,
you're staying warm because the dry is
close to your skin and then the heat
comes off your skin and it can dry out
that stuff better.
Yeah,
exactly.
In your body heat,
you're like your natural,
you know,
your natural zone,
how much heat and how much moisture you
push out is a major factor.
Um,
and especially when you get into some of
your waterproof breathable,
um,
membranes and things like that.
That's something that I think really
would surprise a lot of people when it
comes to hunting clothing.
They really would have no idea like how
much,
how much,
how technical the stuff is and how much
thought is put into it.
And how,
how,
like involve the processes of creating
this stuff.
You know,
it's funny because we all kind of came
from the traditional,
like ski,
snowboard,
snowmobile world,
you know,
grew up skiing.
And so we've been,
you know,
involved in having super technical
clothes since I was eight years old.
Right,
right.
All the underwear stuff,
Merino wool,
all the different policies when that
Kinda came out and replaced cotton when
I was a kid and you know,
um,
they were great.
But it wasn't until we kind of started
using marina that we found something
that,
I mean,
you know,
if you go skiing or snowboarding or some
sledding snowmobiling,
right,
you sweating bullets and if you get
stinky,
whatever,
it's just how it always was,
you know.
But for hunting,
it's a really a big deal,
you know,
if you can possibly kind of shrink your
stink footprint just by a little bit,
it can be the difference between
succeeding that season or not,
you know?
And so we all started wearing Marino for
whatever,
you know,
all of the other sports,
like skiing and snowboarding and,
you know,
pedal,
bike and,
and whatever.
Um,
and once we found out that it didn't
stink,
that was like,
Whoa,
that was a big deal,
you know,
because you could wear it for days and
days.
And so that was kind of the impetus.
And at the same time I started taking
over,
I would say the traditional outdoor
space,
you know?
Yeah.
And you're.
Nobody
is really popular with public land do it
yourself.
Hunters,
guys who go out backpacking for long
periods of time.
And that's one of the reasons why they
liked that Merino wool.
And one of the reasons why I wanted you
to have you guys on this,
just talk about what's been going on
lately with a hr six,
21 and now hr six slash 22.
These two recent bills.
They pulled her 6:21,
Steven Rinella wrote a big article about
it.
But for the uninitiated,
what these bills are about is there
about selling off our public land,
giving the states the ability to do
whatever they want with it right now,
these lands or federal,
they're owned by the people of the
United States.
It's a very unusual situation that we
have here.
It's an amazing situation and there's
very few countries in the world that
have anything even remotely close to it
where there's millions and millions and
millions of acres that are available for
anybody listening to this to go on you.
It's literally your land like back
country hunters and anglers have that
great shirt that I wear all the time.
It says public land owner and I've seen
you on it.
And I'm going to tweet the picture of
you and I from shot show where I was.
I was with you and you were wearing that
shirt.
Yeah.
That's such an important point for
people because I didn't know it at all
until I went with you guys until I went
with Rinella and the crew.
Uh,
we went to Montana.
That first trip with Brian Kaplan who's
hopefully coming.
That's why that door's open,
folks,
if you're watching this,
we're leaving that door open because
Collin is trying to make his way over
here right now,
but I didn't know that this public land
system even existed and I think most
people are unaware.
They just don't.
They don't understand how unique this is
and how incredible like the,
our forefathers,
like their,
their,
their vision to make something so
incredible that no one can go in and
just fucking put malls up in
it is an amazing thing and I think this
is like the easiest battle in the world.
If we can somehow tell people your kid
communicate even a fraction of our
appreciation for it.
It's just,
it is the reason I get up in the
morning.
Well,
especially where you guys are
[inaudible],
you guys are like,
you're in the boondocks man.
I mean you guys are in Idaho and you're
in a beautiful area,
but you could literally like go out your
back door and make a straight line
through public land for forever.
Like you could just go walk and
disappear.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
we can walk straight north and cross,
uh,
two highways and one interstate and keep
going across the Canadian border,
cross to more highways and be in the
Yukon basically.
So it's a wild junker ground.
It's amazing.
It is.
And it's open to everybody.
Everybody,
you know,
it's,
it's an interesting issue because
sometimes you know,
you'll get mountain bikers,
you get after the equestrian people or
the.
Yeah,
the,
the hikers get after the motor bikers,
but it's an issue for every single
person because no matter what sport you
do or how you choose to enjoy the
outdoors,
that's your land.
Once that's gone,
it's gone.
Yeah.
I mean and there are regulations like as
far as where you can take motorbikes or
where you can ride even bikes,
right?
Even trail bikes,
but that set aside,
man,
there's some amazing country that you
could just go get lost in.
Just go wander,
pitch a tent,
drink out of a stream and you could stay
there for long periods of time and it's
totally legal.
It's totally yours.
Your tax dollars literally fund and
support it and all the money that comes
from buying hunting equipment,
from buying tags from all that stuff is
what pays to keep fishing game employed,
makes sure that people are monitoring
the health and the populations of the
animals that live there and making sure
that no one is breaking any laws.
I mean,
it's really an amazing,
amazing system.
It is.
It's unreal.
And I want to clarify a couple of
things.
You like.
All these national forests.
I'm at any blm grounds.
They all have their own regulations.
So yeah,
you can have of land management for
folks that drill weekend manager.
You guys are deep on the inside.
You're gonna.
Most people listen to us on a,
what the fuck I'm talking about.
That's right.
So different for us.
Have different regulations as far as how
long you can stay camped in one spot.
Um,
typically it's 10 to 15 days and then
you have to move again depending on
where you are.
X amount of,
you know,
sometimes it's 100 feet,
sometimes it's 20 miles.
Um,
and then you can set up camp again,
just arbitrary rules.
It is not arbitrary.
There's some smart folks out there that
I'm study the impact of man on the land
and they want to try to keep,
you know,
that pristine experience that we all
love to go find right there for
everybody.
And they have an incredibly tough job
because their mandate,
their federal mandate is to manage that
land for everyone.
How did you guys become a company that's
so connected in people that do go into
the outdoors and people that do hunt
and,
you know,
enjoy your products.
You guys are like really connected to
public land conservation and you know,
and these do it yourself,
public land sportsman,
like you guys are like very,
very connected in that world.
Like it's very,
it's a very respected company in that
world.
Thanks.
I mean,
you know,
we do,
we see it from all angles,
you know,
all of us have.
And you know,
in the summertime we'll,
like I said,
we'll ride mountain bikes and the
wintertime backcountry skiing.
It's all of a sudden,
you know,
and then hunting,
of course it's huge.
But you just see it from all angles,
like places that where you recreate 365
days a year,
all of a sudden you start to get sucked
up and it's just like,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
You know,
like if this wasn't,
if we didn't have public lands,
we wouldn't have a business,
right.
It,
it,
it would just wouldn't exist.
You know,
decision.
Our board of trustees didn't say it's
high time.
You
look at the United States being only
founded in 17,
76 and you just look at the massive
amount of land we occupy now with.
There's just a greater Los Angeles area
where there's 30 million people and you
know,
you go up all through the Pacific coast
highway and just see all the cities and
see all the buildings and see all the
stuff that you would encounter if you
try to try to drive from California to
New York.
The only thing that's stopping that
whole fucking area from being covered
with buildings and malls and gas
stations and anything else they can
stick in there is the fact that it's
public land.
It's that.
It's,
it's federally owned land and you can't
build on it.
There's some folks that want.
They want it.
We drove that,
what does it trip Panga Topanga Canyon
and I was like,
oh,
there's a good looking house.
And I was like,
Oh God,
there's houses everywhere in here.
And then we came around the corner and
there's a sign that says open space x
amount.
And I was like,
yeah,
cover that to open space up.
Gary said that open space that opened.
Wonder what they mean by that.
Whenever it's like,
oh,
orange sign on it right there.
And it was like,
like a park.
Oh No,
like a for sale sign for sale.
Still Open.
Yeah.
There's a lot of development up there.
Topanga is very unusual though because
if you live in Los Angeles,
you could be in Topanga and look like
you're in the woods.
It's cool.
I got gotta say,
and then right now it's all greened up.
It's beautiful right now.
It's spectacular right now.
I mean it would trick you if you came
here from somewhere else,
like,
oh my God,
this is the most beautiful place ever.
When you come back in August,
you're like,
this is a fire hazard.
We gotta get Outta here.
Everything's dry.
And people were throwing cigarettes out
their car.
Windows Kenton's this year.
Yes.
Audio files.
So when you're driving up the road,
you know,
we opted to go over the specific coast
highway and then come over that way.
Um,
Adelaide,
La and it's like,
Oh man,
I bet neil young.
Yeah,
I bet he had.
I mean there was a house that was for
sale in Topanga.
Then I found out about it before it was,
it was already sold by the time I found
out about it,
but it was a house that Jimi Hendrix
owned.
It's like,
fuck,
I would buy a house that Jimmy Hendrix
owned it.
The garbage can that.
Yeah.
I mean that whole place was just hippies
galore up there.
It's a really interesting spot.
Yeah.
Oh,
six,
21 hr six,
21.
Uh,
what does hr stand for it?
I believe it's house rule,
right?
Is that right?
So now we're going to have to google
that up.
I'm,
I'm not real good on some of the notes
here.
And we'll get it for us.
Six 21 was um,
basically to authorize the sale of pre,
uh,
approved lions.
Three point $3,
million acres of a federal federally
managed land that had been designated as
I'm basically disposable,
right?
No.
How did they decide what disposable and
what's not?
Fantastic?
Asked a question
I've asked a ton and I don't know.
I don't know.
I certainly haven't talked to anybody
who was on that committee that came up,
uh,
under Clinton,
I believe.
Three million acres.
Three point three minutes.
Seems like a lot of Jesus.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
Hr just means it started in the house.
Okay.
How's the representatives?
Hr,
and then a six slash 20 slash two.
So 6:20
ones off.
Right.
I pulled it after the backlash and his
name is Jason Chaffetz.
Is that essays name?
Yep.
Representative Jason Chaffetz,
Utah.
And what's crazy is this guy's a hunter
and a fisherman.
And apparently he took a picture with
him wearing Kambo.
Hey guys,
I'm going to.
You will come on and stop attacking me
because as soon as people found out
about this bill,
his comments on his instagram page,
we're just overwhelmed with hunters to
just took over his instagram comments,
you know,
and were really upset and some people
kept it classy.
A lot of people didn't.
And I'm sure he felt that.
The heat of that.
Yes,
absolutely.
Which is a really interesting like now
because of social media because the guys
like you guys and I mean there was a
million people.
The Gritty Bowman Rinella.
Uh,
I got involved.
There's a lot of people involved and
there's a lot of different,
you know,
you look at all the.
If you calculate all our followers up of
all the different people that were
making posts about this,
it reaches a lot of people and then it,
it gets people who might've been like me
before I went with you guys to Montana
who just might have been curious.
Like,
what is this all about?
Then you read into it and then you start
looking into this public land system
that we have and how unique and
beautiful it is.
And you just go,
wow,
they want to sell that.
And Paul Ryan had proposed that as well,
right?
Didn't he propose selling it off to pay
some,
some of the land off to pay for the
debt.
It's something that comes up all,
all too frequently because,
I mean,
it's,
uh,
it's something that we've watched,
you know,
state by state,
by state.
Um,
do you know,
it's like you get a bad fire season.
I'm all of a sudden you're up to your
eyeballs in debt and it's raised taxes
or it's sell off some land,
sell off some land.
So short,
shortsighted,
you know,
when you think about the possibility
that this land
could not be there for your children or
your children's children.
Like it's been for us and it's been for
our grandparents.
I mean it says an amazing system that we
have here.
And what is her six slash 22 k?
So Hr six,
22 is
right now.
It is very black and white.
It's basically to remove,
um,
federal law enforcement officers,
Elios,
um,
which,
the blm has its own law enforcement
officers.
Um,
forest service has its own law
enforcement officers,
um,
remove those and then give county law
enforcement,
uh,
the authority to enforce laws on
the federally managed lands.
Huh.
So if their resources are tight,
which they are,
they probably wouldn't stop poachers.
They probably wouldn't do a good job of
keeping people of,
you know,
making a mess out of the place.
Yes.
And
basically what it does is it sets the
federal land system up to fail.
It's like a booby trap.
It's like,
alright,
now we're going to pull,
you know,
all this,
all these resources out.
And then five years later it's like,
oh,
look what a disaster it is.
Now it's moving to state,
you know what I mean?
It's weakening the structure of it to
facilitate a collapse.
Yes.
And there's nothing,
there's nothing against county law
enforcement here.
The thing is,
it's like,
you know,
you go grab your local sheriff or
sheriff's deputy and say,
Hey,
uh,
you know,
how many mushrooms can I pull off of
this burden on,
you know,
the siebler national forest.
I mean,
that guy is going to look at you cross
eyed,
you know,
uh,
ask them how many cords of wood you can
go up and cut for your fireplace in the
winter.
You know,
the guy's not going to have a clue
because it's not,
not as job.
Bigger fish to fry got totally different
laws,
right?
From federal state for federal versus
state and yeah,
I mean it's a different job.
Now explain to people what is the
difference between Blm and the other
organizations that control
public land.
Okay.
So beautiful in management.
Yeah.
So the homestead act or at a go west
young man,
everybody gets a 140 acres.
Um,
the uh,
so basically we got pushed a lot of
people out onto this big open space
because uh,
you know,
the east needed money,
so you really need to populate these
areas and start the economy rolling
again.
Um,
the basically that area's that failed
like a large chunk of the Missouri
breaks his block,
land management or bureau land
management.
Um,
the areas that failed and were not
hospitable became blm ground.
And basically the impetus a blm is,
um,
they're,
they're more revenue focused then your
forest service lands are so blm,
um,
is,
is more focused towards grazing.
Um,
so Lisa's like oil and gas grazing
and the grazing lease was the big thing
with the bundys.
That was the big thing up in Oregon
where there's a standoff with the
rangers and all that jazz,
which is fucking chaos
chaos.
But they owed a ton of money.
Yeah.
And they didn't,
you know,
didn't want to pay it.
They always a ton of money.
Yeah,
they still do.
But how does that work?
Because we've been on hunts before,
like we were recently with Rinella and
crew.
We're in Nevada and we're on a mule deer
hunt and you know,
you'd be stocking on a mule deer.
And these fucking cows were everywhere.
I mean everywhere.
I mean if you were hunting cows,
boy you will be gold in like,
dude,
we're eating good tonight.
And cows everywhere.
But we were hunting deer.
So you have to get away from the fucking
cows to get to the deer and the cows
that sometimes spook.
And then the deer would realize that the
cow saw something and they would boil
Boeing where the cows are going to come
check you out.
He would step in cow shit everywhere.
And I was like,
this is so crazy.
How are these,
how does this work?
And you know,
they were trying to explain to me that
these people just sort of let these cows
wander.
And we've found that in Montana as well.
Yup.
And we just let their cows wander all
over the place.
Then they round them up.
Yeah.
And that's something.
So the,
you know,
we,
the people have,
uh,
have these programs in place to where we
lease that ground.
Um,
I,
I would say more often than not,
if not a 100 percent of the time far
below market value to uh,
you know,
the rancher and it's right of first
refusal.
So the first guy to say,
hey,
I want to graze my cattle on this
property.
He's his name is going to be on the
lease until he doesn't want it anymore.
And it,
and it comes up for renewal.
And then,
um,
you know,
there's a range land biologists,
um,
who go out and they say this is how many
days and how many,
um,
you know,
animal cow,
calf units,
um,
can be grazed on this area for this
long.
And doesn't that affect local wildlife
as well?
Because I would assume if you're having
your animals graze on the land,
they're eating a lot of stuff that the
deer would eat or maybe a lot of the
other wildlife would eat.
But you gotta keep in mind Ma'am is a
tough call.
I mean,
yeah,
for we are,
you know,
the,
the low lands,
it's the antelope and the and the uh,
and the antelope and the cows live
pretty harmoniously.
In fact,
a lot of that,
you know,
if there's a lot of grand day used to a
lot of cow feed and you know,
it,
it could help when done properly it,
it works really well because,
you know,
basically our beef has replaced our
bison or buffalo.
So there was a major grazer out there
prior to the beef being out there.
Um,
you know,
super dance grasslands are good for some
things.
But,
you know,
oftentimes your upland birds need open
areas,
um,
uh,
for,
you know,
picking up scratch and it's better for
the bugs and a number of reasons.
So when that systems respected and done
well,
um,
it's,
it's good for everybody or it can be
good for everybody.
Now,
what are your opinions that you,
I'm sure you guys are aware of this
whole American Serengeti project that
they're trying to do in the midwest of
this country or in the middle of this
country,
which is really quite fascinating.
They're trying to buy up private land
and turn it into what they think was
essentially like what America was before
people came here.
Yes.
And I am not,
I'm not super studied up on it,
but yeah,
that is kind of the nuts and bolts of
it.
And at the end of the day,
if it's going to be privately held,
and I,
I want to say nature concern,
American prairie reserve.
There it is right there.
This is a little piece on it that a
jamie just pulled up,
but they want to reintroduce bison like
wild bison all through out areas.
Wyoming,
Montana,
Wyoming is a bunch of different areas.
Right.
Where is it?
Yeah.
Ultimately it's bigger than just being
talked about in a number of different
states.
But yeah,
I think it is kind of the traditional,
you know,
the um,
yeah,
the kind of the Oklahoma,
South Dakota,
North Dakota,
like the true prairie region there
where it used to be like giant herds of
buffalo wandering through the land.
They want to recreate that and they're
also gonna open up block management on
that.
Right.
So this is going to be an area like once
it gets established and once there's
populations of animals there,
then people are going to be allowed to
hunt those animals.
Yeah.
And I mean if,
if that's the case,
that's great.
Like I said,
I haven't been super studied up on it,
but you know,
I mean I love the idea man.
I mean
translating,
you know that they're doing this and
buying a private land as right now being
used for whatever and they're going to
turn it into public land and they're
going to allow people to,
uh,
to go.
Then you're going to be able to see like
great herds of bison roaming through
some of these states.
I mean that.
That's going to be incredible and that's
something we always talk about on this
land transfer stuff.
You know,
once it's gone,
it's gone.
So if these guys are out there trying to
make some more of it.
Yeah,
I say good on them.
They literally are trying to make more
public land,
which is kinda crazy.
What are you going to do about Predator?
So they're going to bring in predators.
So they're going to bring in wolves and
man,
if they're going to say that Jim,
here we go.
Does the APR at 10?
Intend to reintroduce predators such as
wolves.
Grizzly bears,
which are historically present in the
region as a non.
As a private nonprofit organization,
American prairie reserve does not have
the authority to reintroduce species to
the area even at those species were
historically present.
Species reintroduction falls under the
jurisdiction of Montana fish and
wildlife parks and slash or the US fish
and wildlife service in any decisions
regarding the reintroduction of wolves
or grizzlies in the region will need to
be made by these agencies augmented by
the will of the general public.
Interesting.
Yeah.
We're reintroducing grizzlies have tubs.
Xcel people like going for it though.
Oh,
I'd Montana.
It's crazy,
right?
An area that you and I were in Missouri
breaks.
I mean,
that's east of the mountains,
right?
Right.
Um,
they every other year,
so they catch some loaner.
Typically a young male is way out in the
prairie and it just looks like he's just
kind of naturally getting funneled down
in the Missouri breaks,
which,
you know,
as historic range for them.
And uh,
somewhere along the way he'd gets his
hunger,
gets the best of them and he knocks over
some sheep and that's kind of the end of
them.
But the same thing,
wolves are going to come whether you
like it or not.
Yeah.
How do you guys feel about wolves?
Because you guys are in Idaho and Idaho
has a really interesting relationship
with wolves,
whereas a real love hate relationship,
like I gotta imagine it's to be cool as
fuck to be out at night here.
Interesting sets.
Amazing.
So at first hairstyle banks or was it
before you could hunt wolves and before
that was it was totally unchecked.
It it.
The elk hunting sucked
as they killed all the up because they
came in and didn't know what was going
on.
They hadn't had wolves there in a long
time.
Over 100 years and then explain to
people that there's a reintroduction of
wolves into the yellowstone region in
1990 something or nothing.
Maybe it was.
I'm not positive when it started,
but then
voted on either.
This is a really controversial subject
tomorrow,
sportspeople and also among wildlife
people.
A lot of wildlife people completely
support it.
They think it balances out the ecosystem
and that the undulates,
like the elk and the deer were running
rampant and they were destroying a lot
of the grasses and the plants that would
like provide homes for a lot of other
animals.
And this whole thing was kind of
unbalanced,
just like with beef man overgrazing bat.
Absolutely,
but are so,
you know,
prior to us being able to hunt them and
stuff,
it was,
it,
it really was skewed.
I had no idea how to deal with the wolf.
So for instance,
a pack of wolves would come in the bowl,
a bowl would go out and try to fend off
the wolves and it would just get crushed
by the wolves.
So,
you know,
a bull elk,
anything.
Yeah.
Full boil.
Right?
Right.
But now a days after maybe living
together for.
I mean,
I've seen this,
it's my happening in my neighborhood,
like as we speak,
there's wolves in my neighborhood right
now.
And it literally,
you can tell when the wolves around the
elk,
they pot up kind of,
um,
kind of get into a circle and they don't
try to go out and fight one on one.
They'll just sit there and the wolves
will kind of come in and they work
together.
It,
you know,
and,
and it's,
it's an interesting,
it's an interesting rl cuttings.
Quite good.
And it,
and the elk don't run,
don't run.
They don't split off.
They've kind of figured out this
symbiosis,
like how to live with wolves.
It's,
it's an interesting thing that's
fascinating
because they always did live with
wolves,
you know,
until people came along and.
Well in Elvis tradition,
elves,
what am I talking about?
This is where my mind is elk.
Traditionally,
before people came around,
there's a debate as to whether or not
they were mountain animals at all.
Right?
They were probably spent more time
store starved going through the Nez
perce territory,
right?
Like they,
there are so little game in the
mountains when they were out there.
That's one of the major arguments for
that.
But um,
yeah,
you know,
there's,
there were animals covering the prairies
if,
if you believe everywhere to those
lyrics,
Lewis and Clark,
what kind of makes sense if you think
about it,
because if you see the way they're
adapting to wolves and every animal
adapts.
I mean there's a crazy documentary right
now.
I mean this is a little bit off topic,
but on Netflix rats,
it is so fucking disturbing if you
haven't seen it,
it's amazing.
It's called,
it's called rat.
I've heard about Morgan spurlock,
the guy who did supersize,
me and a bunch of other documentaries.
He created this woo rats,
like their gross.
Everybody knows her gross,
you know,
just when they start pulling Paris,
I did catch a bunch of rats start
polling parasites out and I'm like,
well this one will kill you if you have
an open wound and this gets on you.
You're black.
Plague comes from Ras.
And they pulled a bot fly out of this
one rad that was literally the size of
its head.
It's just this gigantic thing.
And then at the end of it,
they kind of explained like one of the
guys who's an exterminator explains how
smart rats on how much they adapt and
what they'll do is if there's poison or
if there's traps.
They literally the smart rats,
the older rats will hang back and
they'll let a young,
weaker rat go towards the food and you
know,
he,
he gets his fucking head crushed by the
trap and they go,
Yep,
I thought something was fucked up about
that.
Let's get outta here.
And in the union never killed them.
All like to be able to kill them all.
The most effective method that they were
using this documentary was dogs.
They had a bunch of terriers.
It was all these little cute little
dogs,
man,
little cute little dogs.
He would think,
oh,
a little sweetie.
Those little fucking Jack Russell
terriers,
those little suckers were meant to kill
rats.
That's why they made them.
And they just run after these rats and
they're all ripping them apart.
He was ruthless and brutal,
but it just highlights the adaptation
that animals undergo when there's
pressure,
any kind of pressure makes them adapt
and change and they just sort of figure
out what the fuck the problem is.
The Grand Canyon on the way.
I grabbed a.
There it is.
This is a scene in it.
Oh,
there we go.
Look at those things.
Your pith.
Oh my God.
These little fuckers are monsters,
man.
They just crushed these rats and they
rip them apart like they played tug of
war with these rats.
It is.
This is a,
this is not in the movie,
right?
This is just something else.
Just on youtube called riding or riding.
Yeah.
And this is how they read the
countrysides of rats and like really
heavy area.
They don't eat them though.
They just crush them.
Well sometimes they eat them in the
movie.
They were eating some of them.
Speaking to the
parasite side of things.
Kevin and I were cruising down.
Uh,
where were you last night?
See the Kardashians?
Ventura Boulevard?
No,
there is a possum.
Cal grabbed positive by the tail.
I thought it might have been.
I couldn't help myself as possible.
I've ever seen a good idea at the time.
I've never seen a possum before.
I've never seen a boss.
How's that possible?
You're in the woods 300 days a year.
Awesome man.
Wow.
Yeah,
so I grabbed the thing by the tail and
because I wanted to see if it played
dad.
Right,
right.
The thing,
and then immediately I just ran inside
wash my hands because I.
Oh yeah,
I'm in La and I grabbed a pause,
pause guides for sure.
It's kind of AIDS.
So the adaptation is a
hundred percent true.
Those elk,
God punished when the wolves were coming
on the scene and they just figured it
out and figured out that they got
punished by people and they moved into
the mountains.
They realize,
look,
these people though,
the lazy ones,
they want to pull up in their truck and
fucking shoot off the hood and just stay
away from cars.
Let's.
Hey guys,
let's go up here.
That's hard for them to go up here.
They get tired is not that much air.
Let's go higher.
The wolves are super smart.
They don't mess around,
like if once the bullets started flying
they would,
you know,
they were,
there's a wolf quota and rarely in our
unit does it get met,
you know,
so it's
explain that to people that are the
uninitiated.
So what it is is the wildlife biologist,
and this is a really controversial topic
because when they reintroduced wolves,
there was a target population they
wanted to reach and they felt like we
could reintroduce these wolves.
And what's interesting is they got them
from Canada and the guy that trapped
them that the legend holds,
he just found the nastiest,
biggest like,
oh,
you guys want to bring waltz?
Because in Canada,
like where,
where I got this Moose in BC,
they have so many wolves that Mike Hawk
Ridge,
my buddy lives up there,
one of his neighbors,
they took out a cow and you know,
they,
they'll just get these big packs and
they'll just fucking attack things and
roll in it.
At least for that.
A pack of four small nine of them and.
But at one,
I'm not like some Wolf Hater,
right?
No,
no,
no.
By any means,
but it's,
it is.
They are gnarly predators,
like I've seen them,
you know,
kill stuff and it's,
I don't know,
it's interesting to me how people have
this real soft spot for wolves.
Like they're amazing creatures and they
can do amazing things.
They can travel amazing distances but
nice they are not and it's not like this
furry kind of thing.
They're pissed.
Well,
people think of them as dogs because
they look a lot like huskies that we
think of them as some beautiful forest
creature that lives this natural
existence and they do,
but they're also fucking ruthless
predators and they are the only Predator
in North America like that,
that size that operates in packs.
And that's some scary shit,
man.
Coyotes kind of do it,
but there are a lot smaller and you
know,
they're,
they're more going after rodents and
Fonz and little things that they can get
ahold of.
Wolves will take out a fucking full
blown elk.
You've come across it kill and it's that
thing did not die in any sort of a nice
disney sort of way.
Boy and amaze back to the front when we
were in,
um,
bc in that place where I was getting to
with my friend Mike Hockridge up there.
We came across a kill.
It was pretty fresh.
It was a,
a calf,
a moose calf,
and it was just the,
what were the stunning thing about it is
first of all,
it's pretty fresh.
Like you look down at it.
Like it probably happened the night
before maybe at the very earliest,
like a day ago.
And it was fucking hair everywhere.
Like that's what I didn't expect somehow
or another I thought like,
like,
oh,
I didn't expect to see so much hair,
but it's like almost like they shaved it
and it stays for like a long time.
You know,
you could come in the next summer and
it'll be this big,
looked like a carpet well up there in BC
where he lives,
you can shoot as many walls as you want.
There's no quota.
The reason beings that there's so many
of them,
they have to control the population and
they're so fucking smart.
They're really hard to kill.
And so these people that have cows up
there and their various farm animals up
there,
I mean they're constantly under
pressure,
the constantly the threat of these
wolves.
And as well as him,
Mike shot a wolf that came at him and
jumped at him off of a ridge.
He was going up a ridge rifle in his
hand and he had made some howls,
you know,
he,
he can imitate a wolf's howl.
And the wolf saw him and literally was
jumping at him and he shot it in the air
that has asked me using whole Africa
style.
Right?
He's got this wolf mounted in his house
like this with his feet up to remind him
of that scene.
I mean,
that easily could have been the end of
him.
I mean,
he's up there without a,
without a gun.
That wolf could kill the teamwork
aspect.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
That would be horrific.
They're worse.
So we called in a wolf.
So yeah,
we should go back to like the quota
thing,
because this is kind of a pet peeve of
mine.
People look,
I try to encourage everybody at the
office to go to our local fish and game
meetings and the town hall meetings and
things that happened there in Ketchum
Idaho and I'm the,
one of the arguments that came up was
just so backwards,
but it came from a place of.
I can see the logical sequence here,
but typically if there's a really,
really long hunting season on something,
it means that hunters are doing a really
bad job of filling their tags.
Right.
Okay.
So if there's a really short season,
it typically means that hunters are
doing a really efficient job of filling
their tags.
So we have this very long season on
wolves and several people from town
stood up the fish and game meeting and
said,
hey,
this is just immoral that,
you know,
we were putting hunting pressure on
wolves for eight months out of the year.
And the truth of the matter is,
is hunters,
myself included,
are doing a very,
very poor job of putting a tag on these
things.
And I've,
I've called him one in our area and it
was an absolutely amazing experience.
But uh,
you know,
basically are south facing slopes are
wide open or north facing slopes are
heavily timbered and I could hear the
wolf calling below my,
a friend of mine,
Jim is an amazing shot,
a old retired forest service dude.
And he got set up for the shot.
I'm calling it the wolf.
As the wolf's coming up the mountain all
the sudden starts making noises that I
just cannot make.
So I kinda knew I was screwed.
Right.
But it was the vocal range is
unbelievable.
I would look just like barks and woofs
like Wolf's growls.
Like it just sounded like this thing was
getting more and more pissed off.
The closer it got to us.
And that was my job,
right?
I was like,
I'm going to make this thing so pissed
that it just keeps coming and Jim's
going to get a shot at it.
And that thing broke the tree line
probably 500 yards,
made it at a dead sprint,
about 60 yards from the timber all the
sudden hit the brakes,
turned around was gone.
And that is the closest I've ever gotten
to killing a wolf.
And Idaho.
And sought for maybe a second.
Now
there's a lot of people that are
listening to this go,
why the fuck would you want to kill a
wolf man?
You know what do you go to?
Little Duke.
Duke doesn't work.
You know that law?
That's a big one always comes up is your
Dick's small man.
You want to kill a wolf?
What I think is lost on people who don't
encounter walls or who don't understand
the science behind wildlife management
is that there is nothing else that's
going to control their population.
It's only going to be people.
They're going to survive through the
winter and they're going to eat as many
elk as they can,
as many deers,
many whatever the fuck they can get
ahold of as they can.
And especially since they have this kind
of crazy headstart before the animals
figured out that they were there because
they'd never been there.
And over 100 years since they were
extricated from the American southwest
and the,
you know,
what they had done was with wolves.
They had shot like horses,
like wild horses.
Then injected them with strychnine.
Right?
And then they had shot like an Alpha
wolf and rubbed his scent and his glands
all over the meat so that the other
wolves knew that he had been there.
So they thought it was okay to eat that
stuff.
And so they would eat it.
They would get the strict nine and they
would die.
And they,
it was a mass kill off this wolf.
Yeah.
Judas Wolf.
Yes.
So yeah,
there is management,
right.
And the thing is like,
one of the hottest topics in our area
was um,
in the winter,
especially a heavy winter right now,
all your game animals get congregated in
lower elevations,
typically on these south facing slopes
and get a lot of sun heavy winters like
we're experiencing right now.
These animals are basically pushed into
that farm and ranch country.
And those operators down there are
feeding their winter livestock and the
wolves and the coyotes are writing on
top everybody in calving seasons right
now.
So then you get a,
typically a very large,
um,
did rate.
Yeah.
Mortality rates by spikes because you
got animals that are in distress and
there's,
you know,
after birth from the birthing process
everywhere you got easy pickins on the
cabs and a hunters aren't knocking these
down.
So the state and you know,
like a cattleman's association,
we'll go together and fun helicopter
gunning.
So Ariel gunning to go out there and
shoot those animals.
So,
um,
you know,
uh,
I,
I would love to hear the tiny dick
argument.
Um,
well,
he goes,
go a tiny dude.
Why would you want to kill a wolf there?
Beautiful,
magnificent creatures.
And they are.
But it's important to recognize that
there have historically been gigantic
problems with wolves and people.
That's where all the Little Red Riding
Hood Shit comes from the wolves in Paris
story.
I'm sure you're aware of that story from
the 14 hundreds where they killed like
40 people in Paris.
That Paris has wolves in it again.
Do you know that?
No.
Yes,
they're,
the people are being told.
There was an article about it recently
where people are being told to not fear
the wolves that are in the streets of
fucking Paris because they're only
looking for four legged.
Pray like these fucking people.
Don't remember this story from the 14
hundreds,
this historical story where the people
of Paris had to gather together with
fucking spears and quarter these wolves
and killed them in a town square.
It's an amazing story.
Now.
How much of it,
you know,
obviously when you're dealing with
something from 1400,
there's no film,
so we don't know how much of this is
accurate,
but it's a historical story that they
had to kill a ton of wolves and I'm sure
you guys know about the story from World
War One.
The Russians and the Germans had a
ceasefire because so many of them were
getting killed by wolves in Russia.
They decided,
let's go kill these fucking wolves.
Then we'll go back to killing each
other.
I had never heard that.
He never heard.
It's a great story.
I think.
I mean the populous at large,
what they,
I think will benefit the most from it.
There's people on extreme lovers and
extreme haters,
but in the middle there is somewhere in
the middle there's a right thing to do
and I think that the government
definitely puts their best foot forward,
the scientists and whatever to figure
out that balance,
you know,
and I think that to say that,
we need to have,
you know,
10,000
wolves in Idaho is naive because that
would happen for,
for instance,
if they were just let you know,
for procreate at will.
So you know,
these people are trying to be good,
right?
That's the,
that's why they're calling them.
That's why you know that that's why
they're reintroduced him to create a
balance,
you know?
And I think that that's,
that needs to be realized both sides.
Oh sorry,
both sides.
People that don't want any wolves to
die,
they don't want Wolf's die because
wolves are amazing.
And then wildlife is amazing.
It's totally.
Well,
you can go to yellowstone and I went to
summer and you'd go and see a herd of
buffalo just chilling on this field,
like,
you know,
and I was there with my kids and I was
giving him,
the buyer knows they're staring at these
buffalo and they're only like 100 yards
away and I'm like,
this is amazing.
[inaudible] like,
and my kids were like,
those are wild.
I'm like,
They go wherever they want and like
that's like in their head,
like that's a wild.
That does just giant,
furry fucking star wars beast.
It's a wild ever forget it.
They'll never forget it.
Yeah.
Do you mean it was sinking in their head
to the,
this is wild,
you know,
because it's one thing if you see
something behind a fence and you go,
oh,
that's a cow.
You know,
we're at a farm,
that's a cow.
And I'm like,
no honey.
Those things live in the woods.
They go wherever they want.
There's no boss,
no one tells them what to do.
They just do whatever they want.
Totally.
Well,
coming full circle,
like the whole wild thing is that,
you know,
with public lands people get to have
these crazy wild experiences.
I e by hunting like there's very little
things that you can do where you go out
and it's,
it's raw,
right?
Things can go sideways and you know,
you can get caught out that I'm in.
It's,
it's,
it's a unique thing to be able to do,
to see these experience,
this wild stuff
mean by get caught out there.
It's like you could go somewhere and the
weather can turn ugly and you can get
snowed in,
get lost in the fucking mountains.
Yeah.
People die every day.
Bob a Bobcat goldthwait had a really fun
video,
a movie rather than he did called Willow
Creek about and the,
the,
the movie was about all the different
people that get lost in the woods and
his movie was saying that big foot was
eating them.
Right.
Pretty ridiculous.
But there is it.
Your is it,
but it was fun.
But bobcat is a nut.
He's,
he's a big foot fanatic.
I was like,
I was trying to tell them from people
that actually go to the woods,
you know,
many hunters see big foot zero,
zero.
It's zero.
How many get hit by cars?
Zero.
Fucking zero.
How many get caught on trail cams?
Fuckin zero and got.
That's the other thing.
Like with the,
the number of trail cams that exist
today in the woods.
I put people put up to scout to try to
find out where the animals are and then
on top of that,
the number of phones that people have
that have cameras on them has gone
through the roof.
But the bigfoot sightings have shrunk.
There's way less of them.
Interesting.
And you to my big foot and it was last
time you saw a ufo video and fucking non
or non our area magic.
He's gonna see a Ufo.
You could.
We have zero light pollution.
Red The qualities.
Insane.
Oh,
you guys must have like crazy skies at
nine,
huh?
Yeah.
You guys must have beautiful
skies on rail.
So we're.
I mean the office is just under 7,000
feet and then within 20 minutes of the
office you can climb to 11,000
feet.
Wow.
Try breathing up.
There is a.
it's difficult.
Bring one of these kettlebells up there
and get yourself a workout.
You feel good,
you feel good,
and then you have,
you know,
a couple days worth of stuff on your
back and your like your wife that you
have to drink so much water.
When there's high altitude.
What's that about?
Just dry.
Generally speaking are we are just low
humidity and deep breathe.
You know,
every time you breathe out you breathe
out a little water,
right?
Yeah.
That's what the mist is.
When you see people at and it's cold
and stuff that's coming out of your
mouth,
that's actually water vapor and it
exists all the time.
You just don't see it because there's
not a big difference in the temperature,
which means your body in the air like it
is when it's really cold out.
I think that's why people are more hung
over the mountains.
Certainly my excuse.
Yeah.
Well I got to be because you're
dehydrated too.
Which is the big factor in being hung
over in the first place.
Right,
exactly.
Like the people that are pros.
They'll pound booze and they'll have a
fucking jug of water.
A buddy of mine drank with John Claude
van Damme and he said,
uh,
this is like way back when John Claude
van Damme was a big movie star doing all
these big movies.
He said he would do booze and he had a
fucking gallon of water with him.
He brought like a milk jug size gallon
filled with water.
So you do a shot and fucking chug the
water.
Like it was really consciously Busan,
which I've never seen anybody do before.
That's oozing.
That's a guy that's going,
look,
I'm not going to stop being a
degenerate.
I'm going to take care of my body in the
process.
He comes to catch into years two and
we'd hear stories about looseness,
but I don't,
I've never witnessed it myself
looseness,
you know,
go into the bars and getting loose.
Getting party in.
Yes.
It gets crazy and catch him.
Apparently he used to throw side kicks
off the roof and shit.
Yeah.
You know,
shots for everyone.
First time I ever heard a wolf,
and this goes back to like the hair on
your arms stand up.
Um,
I was working with a buddy of mine and
the Frank Church wilderness,
or is that just straight north to catch
them?
It's the largest contiguous wilderness
in the lower 48.
Really?
Yeah.
It's huge.
And it tried to get people to.
Right.
We tried to force people in there to
mine and Pharma and it just didn't take.
So there's old homesteads and stuff and
there's some eerie stuff like the
Missouri breaks.
Yes.
Yeah.
Very,
very similar.
This is just kind of a grander scale.
I'm much more timber and stuff.
Your guys' first experience out there,
I think I still think about that because
that was,
I would love to put some of these like
land transfer people out there on that
same trip.
Oh yeah.
These guys showed up.
It was like 34 degrees trying to snow.
Mostly just rain overcast grace guys.
Perfect.
Nothing Mary about it.
Yeah,
it was awesome.
Worse temperature to deal with.
Well then it,
it got
done like nine,
you know,
it was getting real cold,
right?
It was fucking awesome,
man.
It was awesome because it's just,
it's one of the things about being in
the real wilderness is how like
beautiful but lonely it is.
It's kind of lonely.
There's something weird about it.
Like you could die and it doesn't give a
fuck.
You have this illusion like if you died
right here,
if you had a heart attack and toe over,
we'd all be bummed out.
Like God,
we lost Ryan Callahan.
I can't believe it man.
And you know,
we'd be bummed out,
but the woods wouldn't give a fuck.
You would just,
you'd fall dead and everything go.
The,
the humble,
the feeling of humility and the feeling
of insignificance is so overwhelming and
unavoidable that it's just this intense
realization of your piece.
Like where you are as a person,
where you fit in in this grand,
gigantic Mandalah of life.
And it's like it's an
find the for the further.
You go back,
you know,
and you know your full day plus walk
away,
you know,
or you get dropped off somewhere.
You know,
it's like,
Whoa,
we're here.
You know,
it's,
it's a.
it's a cool feeling though.
That's the whole thing,
right?
You're outside of your comfort zone.
That's what makes it so pleasurable.
My friend Adam Green tree went on a do
it yourself hunt in Montana and archery,
elk hunt and he went,
I think he went at least 12 miles in
the.
Might've went more by himself,
shot an elk big fucker.
Oh,
did out by himself.
Four days,
four days a pack out.
So he's got 100 pounds on his back and
he's got to walk 12 miles back and forth
for four days to get this elk out.
That's heavy for folks who don't know,
that is four days of misery for days and
looking around and
whistling through the woods and he's in
decent shape.
Me,
he works out a little bit,
but he's not campaigns,
you know,
he's not like some fucking crazy
marathon,
ultra runner.
He's not as job to be fit.
I mean,
he's a professional bowhunter hunter and
he's got a mining job in Australia and
this.
The other thing,
he lives in Australia,
so even though he brought all that meat
back,
he couldn't even take it home.
He could only eat what he had here in
America and then donate it.
Yeah,
you can't bring it back to Australia.
They don't allow that shame.
Australian Customs.
They won't allow you to meet your trips.
So let's say it did a little bit of meat
and his entire camp out on the first
trip.
That's three loads of just meat.
Eighty pounds load.
Yeah,
I mean that guy brought out a lot.
He brought it all back.
You brought it all back over four days.
But they described it like how brutal
the experience was by himself shooting
this animal.
And then he called a buddy,
um,
to uh,
to help him.
And this guy helped him pack out a
little bit.
Imagine your bones laying there on the
prairie in eastern Montana.
There's a good chance because hunters do
the same thing,
right?
And Game Kinda does the same thing.
Generation after generation generation.
Think about you tip over dead.
There's a very good chance in that
country.
There's probably like a cro or sue set
of bones underneath you.
Maybe somebody's horse.
Bison antic was all stacked up
underneath,
you know,
it does not give a fuck.
Doesn't give as well.
Any of bones out there.
You just joined in the pile
and there's a whole system.
Like the idea of waste is ludicrous.
You know,
like if anything the dies,
it's not going to waste.
Like you're not going to waste your dog
dies out there.
It's not going to waste something will
eat it.
And it is.
That is the whole system.
There is A.
I mean it doesn't seem like it to you as
a person.
You like,
you're not supposed to eat fluffy.
He's my dog.
No,
that's a dog and the dog is an animal
and an animal that dies.
There is a whole system in place for
handling that for sure.
I mean from the wolf and the Fox is
they'll come in and the birds and then
in the bacteria bugs everything and
it'll be gone.
It'll be down to bones and then
eventually something will eat the bones.
Did you take the picture of the artery
bulb?
I posted this year,
had just left the face on and then took
all the meat off.
You did an amazing job.
That's so important to post too because
you didn't waste an ounce of that meat.
You cut every in between the ribs,
you know,
you were.
I mean,
and people were commenting on that photo
like that is the respect that you give
an animal when you hunt it and you shoot
it.
That's the right way to end.
Yes.
Now the reality and I think so too.
And I,
I try to go above and beyond.
Yeah.
I'm an organ meat guy too.
I love heart and liver.
I got a need.
I'm going to start with tongues this
year.
I was thinking about your liver.
Oh Dude.
I had.
That was the worst thing to be vocal
about ever.
I used to.
I used to get called up all the time,
like,
Hey,
I got a tongue for you because I know
you like him right now.
It's just overwhelmed with tongues.
Everybody keeps their time and they keep
their tongue out of the bag.
It is,
but you will love it.
But,
um,
the thing is like,
yeah,
you should take every single thing,
but there are little things to get
wasted and like the rib meat chunks,
especially later in the season when
there's not a lot of fat on these
animals,
like if it's,
if it's going to take you some time to
get out,
that's the stuff that's going to get
super dry it out right before you can
even make something out of it.
So,
um,
you were saying about liver.
Oh yeah.
So you made a comment that you eat a lot
of liver.
Yeah.
Like is that,
is that a typical la dish?
No,
no,
it's me just organ meats really good for
you.
It was so high in vitamins and iron.
It's just.
And it's just something about,
it just feels good when I'm eating it,
you know,
that's all I had read about wolves that
wolves.
Like that's one of the ways that they,
um,
that they established the alpha.
The alpha is the one that eats the
deliver.
When he killed,
when they kill an animal,
the Alpha immediately leads to liver.
Yeah.
There was this guy that was living with
wolves and he had these wolves sort of
convinced that he was a wolf and a,
it was,
he was a wildlife biologist and a both
expert,
and I forget where this was,
that he was doing it,
but it was a whole documentary on it.
And,
but one of the things that they never
cry wolf,
I don't remember the name of it,
unfortunately.
Maybe Jamie can find it.
But one of the things that this guy did
was he would put a liver in a downed
animal,
like they would kill an animal,
place it put,
uh,
a liver in it and would eat the liver in
front of the other wolves so that he
would be the dominant male.
And where he got fucked up is he had to
leave because it's a wolf expert.
There was a farmer that was being
inundated by wolves.
So they had set up this whole way to
keep the wolves away from this guy's
property without killing them.
And one of the things that they did was
they set up all these speakers and they
projected the sounds of these alpha
wolves with these giant speakers.
So like,
look,
bitch,
there's a new fucking king just moved
into town.
Everybody get the hell away from these
sheep.
And they set up these big ass speakers
all over and it worked.
But it took a long time to keep these
wolves away like a couple of months.
And so when he came back then there was
a new alpha that had taken his place and
he wanted to kill him.
And it's a horrific scene where this guy
is standing there whimpering in front of
this wolf and this huge wolf is in front
of him bearing his teeth.
And just thinking at any minute,
this wolf is just going to tear this
guy's fucking face off.
This real.
Oh yeah.
It's 100 percent real.
Yeah,
it's 100 percent real.
It's gnarly.
When the wolfs in front of me and he's
like,
and he's got to hope that this wolf does
not decide to attack him.
That shows him mercy.
Yeah.
He established a friendship with this
wolf and he was the Alpha,
the point where it's going to accept the
changing of positions and he has to show
no resistance to this change.
So it's a really critical moment in his
fucking life man,
because it might end right there with
that wolf in a bad way.
I mean,
you know,
everything's happy when there's food
around.
So if,
if late in the season and food scarce,
that would be a tough proposition of.
Yeah.
Early in the season when everybody's
happy,
that's calves on the ground.
Easy pickins.
Yeah.
I was reading this article about bears
and this one region of Alaska,
whereas this salmon run and it's a.
We had a video of it where there's a
guy,
I'm sure you've seen the video because
it's a famous video where this guy is
sitting there,
he's got a little lawn chair and they're
taking photographs of the bears and this
fucking Volkswagen bus with hair walks
up to him and just hangs out and there's
no danger.
There's no fear because it's bear.
It's fat and there's a salmon
everywhere.
And as the guy pans away,
he,
he goes,
get out of here,
bear and the bear,
the bear leaves.
But I mean it's fucking 1500 pound bear.
It's an enormous.
People even get how big they are until
you're right there,
you probably can't know.
But as this guy pans away,
you see that there's just like a dozen
bears and this one area and they're so
well fed this store,
this area historically has an incredibly
low incident or low rate of attack.
There's like almost no attacks by bears
on people in this one area.
This is it.
Food is food is the deal.
Look at that fucking thing.
Oh yeah.
You can sit in this one too.
I mean that is,
that's a tanker.
Oh,
we did.
We contacted you.
Get Ahold of Adam about that fucking TV.
I told them to contact you.
Did he contact?
Okay.
Places TV.
August decides.
That fucker just decides to sit down
behind you.
This TV sucks.
He's cutting out.
Yeah.
So he's.
This guy has to chase his bear off.
But now look,
as the bear goes over,
whatever it means,
got a big fat belly and you turn and you
look down at the river and it's just
overrun.
Look behind you.
Fuck that TV.
Let's see.
Be such a piece of shit.
But look behind you.
Look at all those little bears.
I mean,
that's insane.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
14 bears in just this limited
perspective.
And this guy's taken photos of them
because it's just.
And there's more,
there's just overrun,
just overrun with fish.
We were fishing up in Prince Wales up
Steve's fish shack.
Yeah.
And,
and,
uh,
we had his little boy in the canoe,
so there's three of us in the canoe and
we had,
it was high tide and we paddled away up
this creek and there were six black
bears in this creek that's as wide as
this room and we're just sitting in the
canoe and we kind of pushed the,
the bow of the canoe on the stick.
So it hold us in place.
And Steve's kid,
you know,
being a kid,
he's like bears or bad bears are scary.
It's like,
what are we doing here?
But you could watch these bears take
turns and there was one lane in this
creek and as the salmon would,
the water's dropping right at the tide's
going out.
So the salmon would come up the bear
weight for one to be easy,
grab it,
walk into the woods.
The next barrier would come down,
lay in the same spot,
and just wait.
So it was like a line.
There was a food line and everybody was
totally cool with each other.
We're all going to get some plenty of
food.
No conflict.
I mean,
isn't that the same with people?
Yeah.
It's like kind of universal amongst all
species as resources get scarce.
Shit gets weird.
Yeah,
I mean and that,
that is one of the things that's sort of
important to bring up when people are
talking about wolves and predators and
populations.
Like you can't ensure that these things
are going to have an adequate food
supply,
especially as their numbers grow higher
and higher.
It's,
it's a really controversial subject in
it.
I think the one thing that people don't
understand from the outside that really
don't understand the whole idea of
hunting predators,
they,
I feel like really kind of have to be
there.
I feel like you kinda have to like
almost be just really involved in that
whole ecosystem.
Just be there physically to kind of get
it to you.
I think that's probably accurate.
I think it would be almost odd to be
like,
I'm going to go shoot some animal.
You've never seen no.
Nothing.
You know what I mean?
That would be,
there's a certain cruelty to that,
but maybe,
maybe not,
I don't know.
But once you're,
once you've seen the cycle,
like in person,
it kind of,
I don't know,
it brings everything together if you
will.
You see like,
you know,
wow,
that's interesting that you know,
that they're um,
you know,
that they're around now and I hopefully
don't get too many of them,
but you know,
maybe it's a good thing and maybe,
you know,
certainly in our unit things are.
Elk are fine.
Well,
balance is so super important,
which is one of the reason why places
like New Zealand or so odd because they
brought over imprint incredibly odd.
They brought over all these animals and
the what is like the 18 hundreds,
the Europeans brought them over England
and brought them over.
Is that what it was even earlier than
that?
Earlier in that all the way to say thank
God.
I think Roosevelt gave him a Canada
geese and the Mallard duck and like 19.
Oh five or something like that.
So what they did was they brought all
these animals over there with no
predators at all and so they have wild
stags and these red deer and all these
different animals that are not native
and they're overrun to the point where
they have to do helicopter runs,
unfucking stag.
They have to fly over and
poison poison a whole valley because the
possums or whatever go crazy,
you know?
And there's nothing left to control it.
It's nuts.
And you gotta think the thinking was no
predators,
this is going to be great.
Everybody's gonna get along and it's
going to be.
And we'll have food.
Well the idea was that New Zealand was
going to be an exotic hunting ground for
the wealthy.
It was going to be like a Texas ranch
for.
Yes,
yes.
They were going to come over and they
were going to jolly good time.
I'm going to go hunt a stag and they
would go over there.
And so they put these animals there,
but then they just,
there's nothing killing them other than
people.
And so they're just fucking like crazy.
And making baby stags and just,
whew.
This is a parties.
Plenty of food.
It's all lush and green.
It rains like crazy.
So there's plenty of food.
Beautiful.
Stunning.
Kenton has been over there.
I have not made it.
Yeah.
Did you hunt over there?
It wasn't like,
it was cool.
We just kind of went over there and met
our,
uh,
some of our wool growers and they rented
a helicopter and they kind of dropped us
off in the middle of nowhere.
And so.
So we'll see in a couple days.
Yeah,
exactly.
They could drop stuff on top of this
hill.
We,
I was ready to get out of the bird,
frankly,
it was like crushing snow and I mean
I've been in helicopters a solid amount
and I don't love them and I was like,
I'll walk back,
like,
let's get down.
So we got down and you know,
and just made our way out.
Ended up shooting a really nice shammy
was really wild looking animals wild.
Yeah.
I mean we didn't even know like how big
anything.
We're just out there and we're like,
how does the Shammy shot?
Those are native to that area,
you know?
No,
we took it apart and pet,
you know,
put all the meat and everything and
started walking out and almost left the
head there.
Then like,
let's bring the head,
you know,
it turns out some,
it was like a sci goal.
It would never seen one before.
They're all so small,
you know,
they taste phenomenal.
So that night we got sci.
Gold is always trying to say like the
size of it.
It was like a trophy size down.
That's what I mean.
And it was,
which I thought was just how they fund
all that stuff.
They do it in gold,
they have like silver inches,
but then it puts you into a different
category.
So it's like a 400 inch elk or a 200
inch white tail.
Like there's this.
Yes.
Just No.
Yeah,
like a number that very few people ever
achieve.
Right?
Yes.
But it was um,
I don't know.
I'm not a huge number.
Of course I like to pay attention,
but whatever.
But um,
it's super yummy.
Shammies like super good.
What does it taste like?
Just kind of tastes like,
I dunno,
like lamb.
I would say a cross between like a lamb
under the good white tail.
Look at that thing.
What a weird animal,
isn't it?
Wow.
And they're everywhere.
Whenever I see a big fat guy with a dead
animal with a rifle,
I feel like there's something wrong
there.
Yeah.
How does that guy get up there?
You know,
I feel like you should.
I mean,
this is totally ignorant on my part and
very biased,
but I feel like you should have to be in
shape to kill something that lives up
there.
When I see a fat guy that figures out a
way how to do it,
and I'm like,
all right,
that's a short rope.
Damn short.
Roped with.
Sent me up.
Like when guys climb everest that are
not fit,
they'll have a guide that just basically
short puts a short rope on and
basically.
Yeah,
yeah.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Aggressive guiding.
What is it?
What the fuck is wrong with someone that
doesn't get fit and want to climb
everest?
I just think that they have no idea what
it's like to be above 8,000
meters.
Like they might sit there and go on the
treadmill every single day and I don't.
I don't know.
Meters is what's really important
because 8,000
feet sucks at east.
I lived,
when I lived in Boulder,
we were at 8,500
feet and I would do my kettlebell
routine at 8,500
feet and it was just like,
was like trying to like run through
water.
It was like,
Jesus Christ,
this is hard to do.
It was incredibly hard to do so much
more difficult than it is to do at sea
level.
I couldn't imagine went 8,000
meters is like
narrow.
It's like three percent.
I think you lose something like three
percent efficiency every thousand feet.
You come down to sea level and feet
every thousand thousand meters,
you're talking about 24,000,
25,
26,000
feet and it's insane.
It's insane.
Then you come down to sea level and for
me I'm like,
ah,
running's pointless.
This is been running for a while now.
Yeah.
That was one thing that I noticed when I
did live up there for,
it was only like for four months,
but when I'd go down to sea level,
I felt like I could fucking run through
walls.
Yes,
I can now I get why those guys like
train at elevation and then go and fight
at sea level because that's a big thing
with fighters.
A lot of them were trained in Denver or
up here that go to big bear.
Sure.
It goes away fast though.
It literally like you're,
you acclimate here probably back.
I don't know.
It seems like not
five days in your,
you know,
it takes the same when you go back up
though,
if you've been at sea level for a while,
you go back up.
It takes awhile before you're kind of.
Yeah,
I think,
yeah,
I think they say that the best way to do
it is actually to train at low altitude,
but to live at high altitude so
[inaudible] you could put in more work
so like you go down for the training,
like say if you were next to big bear,
you would drive down and then train it
like you know,
wherever down there and then bust your
ass and San Bernardino or whatever and
then go back up the hill and sleep and
eat and do all your stuff at high
altitude.
So where your high workload is like for
the maximum efficiency of your training
because you could get a 100 reps in it
will elevate.
Exactly.
Get more work in.
You can do more work.
You can and you can do it also for
fighting.
It's super important to not be tired
while you're doing certain technical
work like you,
you're going to be certain amount of
tired,
but you don't want to be exhausted
because your brain doesn't work,
right?
No,
you drop your hands,
you develop shitty skills.
You,
you start making errors in your
technique and those errors and you
technique will manifest themselves under
pressure.
So it's like one of the things about
fighting is it's super important that
you do everything in training exactly
how you would do it if your fucking life
depended on it.
And if you don't,
you're going to pay a price like guys
who slack off in training.
They almost never become champions.
I mean,
unless you're some physical freak who
can get away with it.
The reality is in order to compete
against likeminded people that are also
phenomenally fit and motivated and
understand the consequences of not being
fit and motivated and well trained,
you have to do everything right.
And especially now like mma,
you can get away with a lot.
When I started,
uh,
doing commentary in 1997,
you could get away with a lot because it
wasn't not a lot.
I mean just the level of competition
just was not the same as it is now.
But now the people are so good that the
margin of error is so small.
The difference between victory and
defeat is so small that it's just so
much high level activity going on in mma
fights that you can't,
you can't fuck around and anywhere where
your nutrition with your recovery,
with your,
you know,
like all the different things that
you're doing outside of training,
like cryotherapy or floating or all
these different things that people do.
Sauna,
it's another thing that a lot of guys
do.
All those different things are like
hugely import because these little tiny
edges but also technique like your
technique has to be efficient and it has
to be correct so that in the heat of the
moment you,
you're,
you never think of doing things wrong
because you've never done anything
wrong.
Every time you're training,
you're doing things correctly and that
might not even save.
You still might get head kicked,
so you're basically,
you're,
you're at when you're at your worst,
you're still the best yet.
Well,
there's no,
that's the problem.
The best fluctuates when you're dealing
with like world championship level,
right?
Like say like a division,
like say the UFC is 170 pound division,
very competitive division,
so competitive that the last title fight
resulted in a draw and one of the first
draws.
There's only three draws and the history
of the UFC and title fights.
So this fight lines have been a draw and
then there's a bunch of other guys fuck.
And just straight killers waiting in the
wings to have their shot at the title.
So in any given day one of these guys
might be able to be one of those guys,
like one of these guys comes in a little
bit sick as a little bit of a cold from
training or maybe they're breaking up
with their girlfriend or heads a little
fucked up,
which happens a lot.
Yeah.
It was like,
stay away from the ladies.
Ah,
that's bullshit.
Yeah.
Sometimes sometimes it's actually better
to have sex because then you're not
thinking about sex,
you know,
but everybody hasn't really seen mindset
all the time ran.
It's like,
yeah,
you got to be off the ladies if you're
going to train.
A lot of fighters do think that though,
like a Hixon Gracie was one of the
greatest Jujitsu fighters were all time.
He wouldn't have sex for like months,
months out.
Now.
Andre's just furious to be a Mike Tyson.
Mike Tyson would get his dick sucked
right before he knocked someone the fuck
out.
He didn't give a shit.
He was like that.
Both you and I'm here for.
I'm like,
here's a great quote.
Mike Tyson has a great quote.
He said,
uh,
if a god invented anything better than
pussies,
keeping it to himself so he would have
sex like right before he fought and just
destroy everybody.
So an interesting put that in
perspective.
It doesn't make any sense.
He's not known to be a wordsmith either.
That's actually not the most educated
guy obviously,
but not a stupid man and any by any
stretch of the imagination.
I heard that show.
He did,
it was fantastic.
I heard it's amazing.
I never got a chance to see it that uh,
I saw the documentary,
but I never saw the live show is live
show is supposed to be amazing.
Oh,
you did a standup show.
Sort of.
Yeah,
like a,
just a story of his life.
Yeah.
It's supposed to be just insane.
Everybody that has seen it said you got
to see it.
It's amazing.
That's cool.
Yeah.
But anyway,
sex for him.
Yes.
He would have the sex.
It's not for everybody.
It's just.
I mean it's certainly lower your
testosterone a little bit,
but I mean if you're fit and prepared,
it might relax you where you get a good
night's sleep,
you know,
because that's one of the things about
these guys is like anxiety,
staying up late,
you know,
just trying to get your shit together,
making sure you get a good night's sleep
so you could,
you don't get sick.
Don't let the.
Don't be overwhelmed by the pressure of
the moment.
It's a lot going on.
Helia and you know,
you've,
once you've introduced the possibility
of just getting the shit kicked daddy,
that raises the anxiety significantly.
Sure.
That now think about the anxiety of
releasing a perfect arrow on a beautiful
animal.
You know,
there's a lot of anxiety involved in
that and it's something that people on
the outside,
I've heard people say ridiculous things
when it comes to hunting,
but one of the most ridiculous things
that people have to say is,
you know,
there's no skill involved in that.
All you're doing is you're shooting a
defenseless animal like do you,
you have no idea.
You don't know what you're talking
about.
It's insanely difficult.
It's so difficult to keep your shit
together and that moment.
And if you're a person who is
compassionate and who understands the
consequences of wounding an animal and
what's what's at stake here,
and you know,
the responsibility of making a perfect
shot and in a clean kill is very anxiety
filled moment.
Absolutely.
And I'll tell you right now,
you know,
I've been around a lot of death.
I'm not necessarily by my hands,
but you know,
doing the guidance gig and stuff like
that.
Um,
I,
I did not ever think I was susceptible
to that anxiety of being behind the
trigger because I'd been around it so,
so much.
So what I'm trying to say is once you
get that skill to be column behind the
trigger or on the string,
if you're releasing an arrow,
it's not necessarily something that's
going to stay with you.
Right.
It's not an automatic deal because I
missed the largest mule deer in my life
this year with a rifle that really art.
No.
Where's Neil dear?
I've ever seen no bigger than the one
that you killed with Steve.
Yes.
That's insane.
That was massive.
That one that Steve killed was huge.
How has it bigger this thing,
man?
I just don't.
We hiked for a two and a half days.
My Buddy,
uh,
Kayla reared and he's the to boiled out
your mule deer skull.
A,
your Montana animal.
Um,
we,
I mean we hiked for two and a half days.
He and he and his wife were having a
baby.
So we were like,
got to make this happen because we're
not going to happen next.
How far in did you guys go?
We were,
um,
seven miles probably.
Um,
so you're going over and under over
elevation climbing mountains.
Yeah.
Basically,
you know,
a big river crossing,
um,
big climb,
try to follow a major drainage up,
couldn't find anything or found very,
very little.
Um,
just nasty,
nasty country.
Finally find one mule deer,
fond sunsetting.
There's a meal,
have your phone on this ridge line.
I'm like,
well,
let's just camp here because we have to
leave the next day.
But that's the only sign,
a little life that we saw.
Whoa.
And so we camped and tyler's all fraught
because he's got this.
I thought this would work out.
It was his spot wasn't my spot.
And uh,
the next morning we get up and just
stare at this hillside.
Kaylee leaves to go take a shit.
And yeah,
four hours later there's a buck crosses
and I can't get a range on my range
finder.
It's too far away and I'm just pissed at
the whole situation.
Kyler comes over and he's like,
hey,
I found some deer,
and uh,
we slipped around and in this tiny
little you had to be there.
It something you could see
from two miles away.
You had to like stumble into this
pocket.
There were seven bucks chasing one doe,
seven year old yearbooks,
Jason Window,
and we're looking at these deer and we
were so far in it.
Typically you're just not going to shoot
a buck for me.
When you're that far in m and a,
when you mean when you say a buck for
me,
you mean a small book.
A smaller book is you've put out so much
effort,
you would like to get an older,
mature animal when you're that far in
the course kind of exceptionally.
Right.
Exactly.
But for people to,
for the uninitiated,
which a lot of people listening to this
are that meet buck,
you would think of like a young fork.
Buck doesn't have big antlers.
So you're talking about you're looking
for a big mature animal looking for a
big contract animal,
which is a difficult challenge.
It's,
there's a lot involved in an animal like
that and it's also an animal that most
certainly as bread,
yes,
spreads genes and so it's a good animal
to take out of the gene pool to allow
other animals to also breed
and in fact this is the only dear only
buck in that group that was going the
complete opposite direction,
so everybody else,
all his buddies were on that doe
following her and he was gone the
opposite direction.
Smart.
He's like,
listen bitch,
I ain't got no time for these fucking
games.
You find me hooker.
Good luck.
Good luck,
honey.
Yeah,
it would probably fucking drove his
Ferrari over the top of the hill,
seal it and my whip be over here in my
mansion and a man.
I had this thing dead to right.
I mean a shot I can make any day of the
week and I missed that thing at 90 yards
with a rifle.
Did you punch?
Was it offhand?
Oh No.
I have a beautiful rest at no excuses
and I just lost your trigger.
Shit,
man.
Don't know.
I know exactly.
I mean,
I had,
I mean it was,
I've been in this situation a lot like
okay,
fears,
undercover,
he's going to step into this opening.
I had had a round in the chamber finger
was off the trigger.
I was just waiting for him to step into
that opening.
Cross hairs were there.
As soon as his nose came into the scope,
I pulled the trigger and went right in
front of them.
Yep.
Oh,
you panicked.
I've lost it because he was just,
you saw those antlers.
I just,
I never even looked at the buck through
my binoculars because I knew.
I just knew how big it was.
How big,
how do you think he was?
If you had to guess,
like inches wise?
I would say once in two lifetimes.
Like I will never see a deer like a to
90.
It was like one of those Arizona's trip
bucks for me.
Yes.
For me,
yes.
But I would say it was well over over
well over the 2:20
mark was wasn't my
for people don't know what that means.
That's a,
that's like me with my arms out.
Like that's how big the antlers are.
If you see that thing,
that is that there should be a lot of.
For me,
there's a of misery and seeing that
thing for it should be a,
a major pat on the back because that's
just something nobody gets to see.
Yeah.
It's super rare,
right.
To for them to get that big.
That's genetics age.
That's a wise animal.
There's a lot involved certainly in that
unit.
Yes.
Yeah.
I mean it was just so over the counter
unit.
Yep.
Which means that for people,
the uninitiated,
you just.
You don't.
For a lot of places like where I just
said the Arizona Strip,
the Arizona Strip is like this legendary
area that borders between Utah and
Arizona and it has these monster mule
deer and it like every year they pull
these just insane deer out.
They've got over 300 inches,
which is just,
it's like the one 10th of one percent of
the world's population of deer.
It's just so rare to see an animal this
big and this one area consistently
produces these animals,
so it's really hard to get a tag there
really hard.
Like you could put it in for 20 years
and still not get it.
What that means is there might be
thousands and thousands of people.
They are.
There are thousands of people that have
putting in for a tag there and they
might pick a very small amount.
Very,
very small amount.
Yes.
So this was like an animal for there and
this is something like,
like I said,
no excuses.
We shoot a ton.
We have a reloading bench in the
basement.
We shoot our bows in the basement of the
office.
We have multiple shooting facilities
that we can go to within 15 minutes of
the office.
Spend a ton of time behind the trigger.
Do you have a process that you do in
your mind,
like when you see an animal in your
about to pull the trigger?
Do you have like a thing that you do?
Yeah,
because they say that that's a good
thing to have.
Like almost like a mantra for our trade
like that more you do it,
the better you are.
Like the way you take care Arrow out of
the quiver,
the way you put it on the string,
like you want that to be.
If fewer just gripped,
right?
It just happens.
Exactly like fighting.
I'd say that same exact thing,
same exact thing.
You're dealing with anxiety and having
this pattern that you've carved so
deeply into your mind and your body,
your neurons that your body just knows
automatically.
Like when I was competing,
there was moments where I did something
where I didn't even know I did it and it
was already basically don't even
remember what the hell you're just
moving on this total reaction and
training.
Yeah.
You know,
and for a archers that moment like you
have to kind of like carve that path
also because like if you're,
if you're fighting,
you get to spar a lot so you get to hit
people a lot.
You get used to the idea of moving away
and hitting someone.
But how often do you get to shoot an
animal?
Right?
I mean,
it's really rare when I shoot one,
like maybe once a six months,
you know,
once a once a year.
If you're a busy person,
if you're lucky,
maybe you go a year and you don't even
get a shot at one because you don't to
maybe get this one trip a year and like
what,
you know,
you go somewhere and like you were
saying,
you didn't see anything until you saw
that fond.
That could have been the
whole trip.
Could have been the happens all the
time.
You Go,
you'll be an outfit for days and days
and days you don't see a goddamn thing.
And then next year comes along and then
next year sucks too.
And then the year after that you finally
get her shot.
Knowing Jesus,
your,
your whole body's just wracked with
anticipation and nerves.
And I've seen people where their legs
are shaking,
their arms are shaking.
Like I've seen videos where guys hunting
elk where you see their arms shaking as
they're pulling back.
Their bodies just jacked with
adrenaline.
It doesn't change and they just try to
keep that pen in the general area.
That animal pull through the shot.
For those of you who don't know,
this is like stepping into a place that
you have never been before.
You're not sure what's going on and you
whistle and a six to 800 pound animal
with big chunks of shirt bone coming out
of its head and it's dick slapping
against the belly,
literally piss all over the place,
wants to come in and either mount you
from behind or beat the piss out of you
or stab you with his antlers.
It's a forest horse with swords growing
out of his head.
I mean,
it's,
it's.
These are,
they're amazing and you freak out,
man.
It is.
But a one every five.
If you're an archery hunter,
once one bowl every five years or one
successful,
uh,
season in five is the national average.
That's why Kim Haines is such a freak
because he has not been a,
he's,
he hasn't been unsuccessful on an
archery hunt since 2009.
And the guy goes many times a year,
how many times a year,
but all the ultra marathon running and
all the weightlifting,
all the crazy shit he does and constant
practice with archery.
He just like when the moments come,
he's the.
He's so dialed in,
he's so ready to go.
It's really,
really impressive.
You know,
I mean,
I don't think people understand.
So when I see people on his instagram
page takes new school,
what you're doing is you're a coward.
Why don't you fight that thing
hand-to-hand,
like you have no idea what you're
looking at.
One 10th of one percent of all the
hunters,
that's what that guy is.
He's the,
he's the one 10th of one percent of the
hunters.
And he's out there being way more
successful than anybody else doing
something that's insanely difficult.
But to the uninitiated or the people
that just have never experienced it,
it looks like he's a animal.
Hating monster was out there shooting
God's beautiful creations,
right?
Sometimes Brian and I'll go hunting with
military guys will come out and I'm back
to the.
Just having the process.
It's the craziest thing,
guys that are really good at this,
you know,
and it's like,
it's almost like a robotic action when
it's go time.
It's like sit there,
pack down,
you know,
just,
it's pretty wild to watch somebody
that's,
that so practiced at that,
you know,
the way they load,
the way they reload on target,
on glass like it,
it's,
it's amazing.
You know,
and you see true pros at,
you know,
well that's a totally different world
when you have to shoot people and
they're trying to shoot you to think of
the anticipation.
The anxiety is involved in shooting a
beautiful deer like you missed.
Now imagine that's some urine,
some foreign land and this is some enemy
guy that you're engaging with and he's
trying to kill you and you know,
like you ain't gotta be.
I mean that's where legit.
Like that's one of the interesting.
Do you know Joel Turner's?
I do.
Joel Turner has a whole series on target
panic for archery.
It's really interesting.
It's an online series.
What was it called?
Something.
See if he could find the name of
traditional.
Yes,
yes.
A like Denver.
Maybe something like,
I'm not sure where he's out of,
but it's an instinct fighting instinct
or something like that.
No iron mind guy.
Yes.
Closed loop,
open loop guy and he's got this whole
system that he's put together and I
actually paid for it and wash it.
Very good stuff.
Very well thought out.
Very interesting stuff.
But a lot of it is on the mindset
because he was a.
He was training police officers.
He's training like Swat team members and
how to keep it together in the middle of
a firefight.
And he actually was talking in one of
the interviews that I saw him in about a
conversation that he had with a police
officer that was in a firefight with a
bad guy and heard this,
heard his words and his instructions
going through an executed correctly and
did the right thing while this guy's
shooting in his car window and glass was
flying and bullets are flying at him and
he stayed calm and killed.
This guy was shooting at him.
But that,
um,
that this process of having a thing that
you like,
a mantra that you relay into your head
that relates to a physical action and
that you drill it in yourself.
So it's like,
it's unavoidable.
Like this is how you do things.
That situation.
We described what the bowl coming in
like,
yeah,
you shake your head goes a million miles
an hour.
Like if you don't have something to fall
back on,
the odds of you making a mistake I feel
are way higher than you.
Successful.
Yeah.
You gotta there's gotTa be a thing in
your brain that you can like press play
on,
you know.
And then once you do that you could like
there was an article that I read
recently about a,
it was about choking and sports and it
was essentially there's the article was
essentially saying that what you have to
do is figure out a process that removes
your conscious mind from the equation.
Like figure out a process of training
where you know what to do.
Like someone's,
you have a basketball,
someone's coming at you,
you juke left.
You go right.
You know how to do this,
you've done it so many times that this
is just a natural reaction and get it to
the point where you don't have to think
about it so you're not overwhelmed by
this moment in the anticipation of,
what if I fuck this up?
Oh my God,
so many people are watching what happens
here.
What if I do that and you'll.
You'll see those moments where people
just lock up and they panic.
You see seen in fighting all the time.
The tradco thing versus a compound or
recurve,
right?
That introduces.
That's when this shit can get crazy
because say with the compound,
you draw back,
you hit the wall,
right?
The bow only drawback so far.
You look through a whole,
you'd let it up with another whole.
I mean,
don't get me wrong,
it's no picnic,
but then you know,
once you start shooting in traditional,
there's nothing that's super repeatable.
I mean you try to do it,
but you pull it back as far or if you
don't pull back far enough,
you goof up.
You know what I mean?
There's no aiming and it's a funny
experience when all the sudden,
the first time you draw back on anime
and you're like,
what the hell is go like there's no
reference,
right?
Your brain is just kind of bouncing
around.
And I think where that,
uh,
what was the guy's name?
Joel Turner.
Yeah.
Where he is just.
And he shoots with us some loop.
He shoots Mongol Scott,
you know,
Mongol style is the Mongols used to have
a thumb ring.
They would have a bone ring.
I've seen it.
They would wear around their thumb and
that's what would fit on the groove of
the string.
So they'd hook the string with their
thumb and then close their index finger
over it and they would draw back like
this.
And according to Dan Carlin from,
if you've never heard this before,
if you've heard me rant about this
before,
I'm sorry,
just ignore me for a moment.
There's a,
there's a amazing,
a podcast series called hardcore
history.
It's by this guy who's a friend of mine.
His name's Dan Carlin's,
says genius historian who's so good at
relaying.
He'll,
he'll say he's not a historian.
He definitely is,
he's super humble guy,
but he's so good at relaying information
in an entertaining and dramatic fashion
and he has a series called the wrath of
the Khan and it's a five part series.
You have to pay for it now.
Um,
but it's like a dollar an episode.
It's so worth it.
It's worth 100 times more than that,
but it's a five part episode on the
Mongols.
And he said that their bows were like
160 pounds raw.
They were just these sinewy fucking
savages that were incredible archers
that were.
They had developed this ability to
release the Arrow as the horse was in
its Gallup.
So when the horse was in the air where
there wasn't a disturbance,
so they would time the release of the
Arrow to when the horse was actually in
the air force.
They had it down and the had a thumb
ring and that's how they would draw
back.
So not with your fingers,
like most people do.
They would draw back with the thumb
loop,
the index finger over the thumb.
And for some reason they found that to
be a better method day.
It's like a,
it's like a,
you know,
it's like a primitive release.
That's the thing with the traffic,
right?
Your fingers,
you can pluck,
you can just hit 100 different ways to
screw up.
Right?
If you had that right,
you let go.
It's probably a lot more consistent.
Well that's the whole,
the other is you could see that that's
the bone thumb rings and a lot of people
like to shoot that way.
Now.
It's really kind of interesting stuff
man.
And see how it holds.
And then you throw your finger over the
top of that thumb ring and you know,
your,
your thumb pushes back on it and you
need your finger,
your index finger closes over the top of
your thumb.
It's not dissimilar to a lot,
to a release a lot of ways.
Yeah.
Like,
um,
when I shoot a compound bow,
I shoot a,
I use a Carter release thumb trigger
release.
It's a good tension is I use one called
the wise choice.
It's,
um,
but I use attention based one to the
evolution,
or is one that John Dudley put out
called the silver back that are really
prepped.
Hurry up.
Go.
No,
no,
it doesn't because it's the same motion.
You know,
the idea is you don't ever pull the
trigger.
You,
you lock in,
you pull in place.
You put your thumb over the trigger.
Then once you're in place,
you concentrate on the muscles that are
in the center of your back and you pull
those and the release goes off and you
get a surprise shot.
So the idea behind that is there's never
a moment in your life now and you punch
it and then you move the Arrow where you
move the boats or did I get it?
I know there's all that shit is out of
your head because all you're doing in
the shot process is pulling and
concentrating on those muscles and the
center of your back and your scapula and
contracting those.
And as you do that,
they released just goes off because your
thumb is pressing against that trigger
and it just goes.
And.
But you have to resist that urge that
everybody has just now now punching.
So that's the difference between like
John Dudley's approach versus Joel
[inaudible] approach like John Doe,
Joel Turner has the same approach and
even talks about it when it comes to
compound bows of using a thumb trigger
of polling and letting you know,
letting the shot go off automatically.
But Dudley,
he thinks that you should start off
using attention based release,
which the way that works is you actually
hold the safety,
hold the trigger until you lock in
place.
Then once you're ready to execute your
release,
the safety and all it takes is like a
couple extra pounds of pulling and it
goes off.
Interesting.
Yeah.
So it's like a Carter evolution or he.
He has one that he makes called the
silver back that is a two finger version
of the Carter evolution.
So he feels like the least amount of
fingers that you have on it.
The least amount of tension.
I mean this is the point to try to do
people like what the fuck are you
rambling about?
What I'm trying to randomly about like
this,
this thing is insanely complicated,
so to the people that look at this and
say,
oh,
there's no skill involved and Oh,
you're just killing this defenseless
animal like is the most difficult way to
get your food.
Yes.
It's the most difficult way.
There's no more difficult way to get
your food than shooting an animal with a
bow and arrow.
It doesn't exist unless you want to
fucking use a spear.
I make.
I guess it is not getting growth.
I guess you could to jump out of a tree
with a knife and.
Yeah,
but that stupid mean,
but it is that,
you know,
the animal comes for your strategy.
Like for me it fit is proficient and
proven.
Be Proficient.
When Kevin and I were making the switch
to go back to traditional archery.
Why'd you guys decide to do that?
Man,
I got so tired of the stuff.
Yeah,
like tough stuff.
Changing every year.
New Sites,
new strings this new.
I got to hate,
hate setting up a compound bow.
I hated it.
Why?
Because there's just so much going on
and like,
Oh man,
is that me?
Or is the bowl out of tune,
did my string stretch
timing and twisting your strings and how
I'm going back
this year,
I'm going to get a job.
I like to cows point plus.
What are you going back to traditional?
Are you going back to compound
back to compound a company is making a
called [inaudible] really nice bose and
our camouflage pattern.
I'm,
I'm pretty excited.
And plus,
I don't know.
I,
I've had very mixed success.
I would say I struggled a little bit.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Um,
but how could you not but the um,
but the,
but frankly that the simplicity of it is
so appealing.
You know what I mean?
It's,
it's fantastic,
right?
Versus setting everything up and plus,
you know,
you get to a point where a modern
compound bow,
if you practice a lot meaning for years,
right,
you,
you'll get to 90 yards to where you are
professional day.
People are going to complain and I don't
know,
it's not,
it's not really that ethical for most
people to shoot at 90 yards.
But it is for a guy like John Dudley or
you know,
a guy like cameron hanes because they do
it all day
first.
Grammy is a very technically proficient
shooter in anything that he shoots him.
He won't say it,
but we used to sit in the ski area
parking lot,
Greyhawk parking lot and 106 yards is as
far as my adjustable site would go on my
bow.
So he would stand there and he could
shoot a lot further.
But I mean the groups that he would put
in at 106 yards were a maze because he's
got that mind to do it so he can shoot,
you know,
I don't know.
But the thing is is that after awhile
you get to the point where I don't want
to shoot something at 50 yards.
I want to shoot my next elk at 15 years.
So you know what I mean.
So I think that's largely it.
And I think without a doubt,
in the past three years I've become way
better hunt.
We have been know both.
I mean cows killed bubble both years
with his trad.
I missed a nice bowl two years ago,
but it's just hard,
you know,
and if nothing else you're going to get
way better at hunting in the sense that
you're going to hunt more because you're
not going to kill shit at first.
Right.
But you know,
being,
having to go from,
let's just say 80 is a Max yard and I
don't want to get into the argument
about distance,
but let's just say that was,
you know,
your Max Max on a perfect situation with
the compound,
with a compound bow down to say 25 or 30
yards.
It,
it's interesting.
It just makes you in your head just so
much more.
You have to try so much harder.
You know,
and I don't know,
I just people that experience,
I have no desire whatsoever to hunt.
Even if you're a lifelong vegetarian,
you're never going to eat me.
Just go shoot a bone Arrow at a target.
It is so relaxing and some weird
meditative way.
It cleanses your mind in some way.
Zen
stuff,
man.
It's like fly fish and kind of same
thing.
It's like you're not necessarily.
I don't know,
you have to concentrate,
but at the same time it's like taking a
nap or something.
You go shoot for 20 minutes,
30 minutes and you're done.
You're like,
okay,
what was I thinking about before?
Yeah.
Oh,
I love to do it.
When I've got like a business issue I'm
dealing with or something I'm trying to
like sort out in my mind.
I just go out in my yard.
I got a big rubber elk out there,
85 yards and they'll just start shooting
that sucker and you see you don't think
about nothing but that shot.
He just sent her that pen.
Try to stay calm,
relax your hand,
let the Bogo off and there's no room for
anything else.
And then in its activities.
Yeah,
and you walk up there,
you pull your arrows that you walked
back,
you're concentrating the whole process.
I don't know.
I think it's cleansing and some sort of
a weird way,
and I'm not a traditional bows shooter,
but I would imagine that was accentuated
even further because a,
it's even more like instinctive that you
have that involved as well.
So like instead of using a site,
you're sort of like calculating in your
mind the drop of the Arrow over distance
you can,
but it can be more frustrating to way
more with the compound out.
I mean,
with the recurve.
I've gone out and shot two arrows and I
was like,
fuck this.
I'm done.
Yeah.
Ken and I are all,
uh,
our uh,
our first accountant gallery retired.
And so we all went out and had some
beers with her and I was a little fuzzy
the next morning.
I forgot my tags.
So,
uh,
I was like,
I'm just going to call for,
for Canada.
And we took off into the woods and
called the Bolin within 20 minutes.
Didn't have a shot at.
Oh my gosh,
this is a great day.
We ended up calling in three mobile,
three more bowls that day,
but the bowl that Kenton got a shot at,
um,
he would have shot four times before it
ultimately came into recurve distance.
Right.
But it did come in.
It came,
I mean it was in four yards at one
point.
Oh my God.
I mean,
it was this,
it was like this close.
That's so crazy to have an animal that
big that close to you.
It was crazy and fed to cows point.
The beauty was,
was that it was hanging up out at,
you know,
50 yards for five minutes and that would
have been the end of that experience.
Right.
I would have not had that same
experience.
And then it comes up and to count what
it licked you basically write in cap and
looking through the Mesh in the back of
my cab.
It's saying it's coming straight towards
me,
but I kind of caught me,
you know,
to where I didn't have a shot.
Um,
and then it went and looked and I missed
it out.
I'll never forget that.
But um,
but it would have been over.
The experience of having,
of having to get that close is really
cool.
You know what I mean?
If like,
like I said,
it would have been done and we'd have
been packing it on.
It would have been cool,
but whatever.
And that would have been incredible to
shoot it there too.
But,
but just to be that close and visceral
and it's like,
holy smokes,
I mean this thing is here.
Yeah.
It's one of the things that um,
I talked about with Jason Harrington
from we were talking about the
difference between like mountaineering
and hunting and it's like all these
things and hiking and hunting.
It's like all these things are beautiful
and they're amazing.
But then add the add to that,
this experience of this really intense
moment with a wild animal where you have
to execute something,
you have to execute a shot and you have
to.
Everything has to come together and has
to come together perfectly.
And that is what makes this so
addictive.
And that's something that man,
I try to relay that to people and I try
to explain it but I just feel like my
words aren't adequate.
I feel like everything,
everything I always say to describe it,
I feel like I'm just rambling and it's
not going to work because you have to
kind of have to see it to understand.
Yeah,
I mean there's very little reference,
right?
And that's what you're talking about.
Like you can say,
well,
it's like,
you know,
imagine,
skiing a perfect,
um,
you know,
50 degrees,
powder line,
right?
Or whatever,
something kind of,
you know,
heavy with consequence.
But it's totally different than that.
It's like it's,
Oh,
I don't know how else to describe it.
It's,
there's certain words like there's no
words for a giant mushroom trip,
you know,
like I've had,
I've tried to talk to people who've
never done anything.
Like,
what's it like,
you see things,
you see pretty colors.
Is it really worth it?
Like you can say,
God,
you just got to take enough.
Yeah,
you can definitely see colors.
But I mean I'm just saying those words
to beat,
but then,
you know,
you talked to somebody about it and then
like a year later they go,
dude,
I did it.
Whoa.
Like a buddy of mine recently just did
DMT and he had talked about it for a
long time and they finally did it and
then he just,
he sent me a text message.
He's like,
dude,
I'm at the elves.
Was like,
oh,
trip.
No,
no,
no.
He texted me after it was over because
he had been thinking about doing it
forever and then it's one of those
things,
unless you do it,
whatever I say,
the way the words that I'm using to
describe their just not going to work.
I think that's the case with so many
experiences in life,
like try to describe being in love to
someone who's never been in a
relationship.
You know,
there's no way you could never do it.
You can never explain the love of your
children to someone who doesn't have
kids.
Who's the dog?
Like,
Oh man,
figure it out.
You know,
and I think certain intense experiences
in life like hunting or he just even
mean we even forget the hunting mean
just being in the woods,
like attempting to hunt an animal is
insane.
Almost psychedelic experience.
It's one of the things that I described
people,
the first trip that we went to,
the Missouri breaks when I shot that
deer,
when I locked eyes with that animal,
the fruit for the first time and I was
sitting on a pack,
a looking down the scope of this rifle
and I was looking at this animal and
then I look at this animal through this
rifle scope and he's looking at me.
I was like,
this is a weird life form that's living
in this very barren and desolate place
where there's no people for miles and
I'm locking eyes with this thing and it
was oddly psychedelic.
It was oddly like paradigm shifting.
Like the moment was so intense and
weird.
I was like,
wow,
I didn't expect this.
Like this is.
This is like.
I mean kind of.
I mean I'm feeling like because this
thing is looking at us,
I'm feeling that this thing is thinking
like what are you and what are you doing
it?
We probably never seen a person before.
What are you,
what are you doing here and should I be
worried
about you?
Right.
He's gone.
That wasn't here yesterday.
Yeah.
What is that?
And you know,
he's always seen is like baseball hat
and then the metal barrel of a rifle and
he's not seeing much.
He just seeing us resting over the top
of a ridge looking down on him and he's
like,
fuck that.
It's,
it's uh,
it's really weird intense experience.
It is.
And the,
because
you do look at things in a much
different way and,
and you know,
kind of the point of talking about all
this public land stuff is I,
I do feel like people who hunt and fish
carry a big load of this burden rent
through the taxes that we pay that or
taxes that if you don't hunt or fish you
don't pay them.
So we've highlighted that on the show.
The actual amount of it we've showed
from the rocky mountain elk foundation,
their instagram page,
they have a really good instagram page
that has a bunch of different examples
of different states of the sheer volume
of money that comes in because directly
because of hunting and fishing and it's
staggering.
It's in the billions and is by far above
and beyond anything else.
By far,
the the largest amount of conservation
money that comes into this country,
the largest by far.
It is so fishermen,
nothing even close.
It's amazing when you think about it
that way in that sense.
This system that we have here with
public land and with using these tax
dollars to pay for,
for all the wildlife biologists to pay
for the fish and game to pay for the
population management.
It's amazing.
It's an amazing system,
but if you're a hiker that your peak
bagger,
right?
You're finding names on the map and
you're like,
I'm going to hike to this lake or I'm an
hike to this peak European.
That's.
We call them a peak bagger bagging piano
bag,
a peak two peaks.
Have you been to?
Yeah,
exactly.
That's interesting.
Peek a big sounds like in that
community,
right?
Boulder?
Yeah.
Fourteeners and bag and a lot of peaks
and people fall off those peaks to man.
Yes.
They get stuck up there.
Sucks,
but you know,
you are taking a trail on established
trail and you're covering miles and
you're getting to your goal and maybe
you're snapping a picture or spending
the night and then you're coming back on
that trail or maybe it's a different
trail.
Whereas one hunter,
as you know,
as soon as you step away from the truck
and
or out the trail head,
you are plotting your own course so
you're making your own moves and there
it is a totally different experience.
Everything means something different to
you.
You're looking at it in a different way.
You're trying to interpret different
signs and your base note path.
Yeah.
And your,
your,
your choices are pretty much limitless.
Absolutely limitless.
Like when you leave,
as soon as you get off the trail you're
just like,
you know,
hopefully you hear,
you hear something or you see something,
you smell something and that begins your
day,
but you don't know.
You might,
you might not leave a 100 yards that day
and you might cover,
you know,
might be a heavy,
eight mile,
you know,
5,000
foot day you don't know.
And that's,
I don't ask the craziest thing,
you just have to be prepared for
whatever.
And so,
you know,
get people who are like,
well,
there aren't any wolves here anymore
because in Idaho wolves were,
you could see them a lot,
especially in Ketchum area,
the Lohmann area there wolves that,
you know,
that they're smart critters,
they know that they knew that nobody was
going to shoot at them.
And so they were a fairly common
occurrence to see.
And then once the season opened,
once they let people go out and they
issued tags,
um,
they picked it up really quick and you
didn't just see them hanging out next to
the road and people said,
well,
none.
Hundreds killed all the walls.
But oddly enough,
the hunters are reporting Wolf's
sightings.
No,
I saw that.
Yeah.
They're not killing all the wolves.
They're killing a pretty small number.
Right?
Job.
As hunters,
we're not,
we're not getting,
getting the numbers that were supposed
to.
So what do they do?
Do they,
are they hiring professional wolf
killers to,
to go after a wolves like they're doing
in California to go after cougars?
Since they killed,
since they stopped the hunting season on
mountain lions,
they haven't stopped killing mountain
lions.
That's something people don't
understand.
Like there was a depredation order on a
mountain lion up in the Malibu mountains
that had killed 11 Alpaca and a goat in
one sitting this big fucker just.
And they know the,
the lion too because it's tagged,
it has a collar on it.
And uh,
this fucker just found an Alpaca farm.
I just went to town,
just had a glory killing spree.
So in California they can't know no
mountain lion hunting whatsoever,
but they're everywhere,
especially in rural areas.
There's a place called to hone ranch
where that bolt came from.
See Front,
there's one lake that they have like a
pond they have out there and they have
trail cam up.
They've got 17 different mountain lions
on trail cam.
Oh my God.
You're about meeting people fairly,
um,
fairly often out here,
huh?
Well,
it can,
it's,
you know,
it's a lot of it's joggers or bikers,
like people on trail bikes because they
think that trying to get away.
Yeah.
And other things.
It's almost like a cat with a ball of
yarn.
They just can't help themselves.
Right?
Or flight risk.
Someone's running the like pitch were
you gone.
But the thing is it's like 100 or are
doing something different than your
typical recreate are out there.
You know,
we're not sticking to a game plan.
So I feel like you're that different
hours.
Different making Predator and prey
noises,
right?
Yeah.
You're just doing things differently.
So I think feel like I get a little
torque sometimes where people think,
oh well of course hunters are going to
say there's wolves out there.
Know it's,
it's.
This is good information for biologists
because we're out there.
Actually our point in the woods is being
out there looking for animals.
Now,
one of the reasons why I wanted to have
you guys on is to really sort of
discussed this public land issue and
also to allow people to understand
what's at stake and to give them options
to look into and to different resources
that they can check in on.
Like,
like a back country hunters and anglers.
A Bha.
Yeah.
Back Balcony,
back country hunters and anglers.
I can't say it.
My mouth starts shutting down after two
hours these days,
but what they're doing is a amazing like
highlighting like what this is and how
important this is and what are the other
things that people could do if they want
to look into this stuff.
Yeah.
So Bha is big,
loud voice and I think they one of the
best groups out there right now to
really just raise awareness.
I'm on public lands and access issues.
Teddy Roosevelt conservation partnership
does a phenomenal.
Yeah,
there it is.
A country hunters and National Wildlife
Federation.
By the way.
You read that there are two folks if you
want to buy that public land owner tee
shirt,
they have it there
now.
Um,
so what the main issue is in Kenton I,
we talked about,
you know,
you have an incredible platform here,
Joanne,
and we don't want to waste it.
So the,
this is a nonpartisan issue.
If you don't like 100 and $800 or
anglers,
that is still your land.
If you never leave downtown La,
all this public land contributes to your
quality of life through clean air,
clean water,
just knowing that it's there should be
it something that is warm and cozy for
you because it is your birthright as an
American
in this country where 95 percent of the
people you meet,
something,
it might even be higher than that.
It's depending upon it and there's so
many,
so many discussions these days about
where your food comes from.
There's no better way to find out where
your food comes from then to actually go
out and get it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
But man,
if if you're buying beef or lamb off off
the grocery store shelf,
those grazing permits that we talked
about,
that happened,
a lot of that happens on federally
managed lands,
whether it's Blm or forest service
ground.
And the thing is this is nonpartisan
again,
and one of the things that ticked me off
about old Jason Chavez,
hr six,
21 and said,
hey,
you know,
this started under Obama,
Clinton or Clinton Clinton took
designated these lands is useless.
Yeah,
who cares?
I don't care.
It was Clinton,
Obama,
trump,
that doesn't matter.
Who Cares?
You're taking the Lexan.
Yeah,
point to back.
It's a nonpartisan issue and I think a
lot of times people would like you to
believe,
Oh,
if you're a republican year against this
or if you're know pro,
second amendment,
you can't vote for that and this,
that and the fact is is that you can,
if you have a Republican leader in your
area,
they can change their mind.
You need to be involved.
Right?
And if,
and if that's the way you feel,
that's great,
but you have to realize that you can't
have your cake and eat it too.
It doesn't have to be one or the other.
Like,
you know what I mean,
you,
you can be a conservative and still be
pro public lands,
you know,
and you need to work and call and do
what you need to change them if they're
not.
Because if,
once it's gone,
it's gone and use social
media because social media is an amazing
tool and that's what killed her six,
21.
It was directly killed by social media
and he was killed quick who was killed a
couple of weeks,
you know the pressure that they faced
from guys like me posting it to one
point 8 million people on Instagram,
one and a half million people on
facebook say $3 million or whatever the
fuck it is on twitter.
Like all those people that add up and
then those people find out about it.
They jump in and they realize that this
is a.
This is a really important issue.
It's a giant issue and Rinella always
points out that he's.
By the way,
Rinella wrote a great article about all
this and about how killing her six,
21 is just one battle in the overall war
and we're not.
There's no not out of the woods by any
stretch of the imagination and that
article is available right now.
If you go to his twitter,
it's on.
I think it's on a meat eater.com.
Is that where it is?
Yeah.
Yeah,
but no,
that's not.
That's one,
but there's one that I tweeted today.
This is the one from January.
Twentieth is one that I tweeted today
that he just recently wrote and he calls
himself a political unit because he's
like,
look,
he goes,
the Republicans want to sell off the
land and the Democrats want to take away
your guns.
He's like,
I don't know where the fuck to go.
You know?
In that sense,
well,
I'm not.
My point simply is that you can change.
You know what I mean?
It's like if you,
you need,
it's not a part.
It shouldn't be a part of your
representatives are there to represent
your interests and this is the article.
It's Roosevelt
robber barons and the continued fight
for our public lands and he just
published it today.
And is that on [inaudible] Dot com?
Yes.
The meat eater.com.
Somebody owns [inaudible] dot com.
Yeah.
Isn't that weird?
Give it up,
bitch.
I'm going to give it up.
What does media to go to?
Meat Dot Com.
What is that?
I think it is it available.
Is one of those things has been just
like a picture of a steak for years.
There you go.
Garlic top sirloin.
It's delicious.
Best Cowen school.
So is this like someone just holding it?
I think the person may have died or
something and they're dead.
Uh,
but.
So yeah,
they have a fork with a piece of meat.
Look,
here is my food,
chicken drumstick.
Look at my food.
Hr Six,
22,
going to gut the folks that are supposed
to be out there protecting our
resources,
making sure people play Nice on,
on public lands.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
the uh,
planning two point,
oh,
just a terrible name.
Not Sexy at all,
but that is the new management plan for
a bureau land management that just got
shut down.
It's going up to the Senate right now.
So the thing is,
if you want to know what you can do,
you have got signed these petitions that
are going around Trc p,
he's got a great one.
The sportsman's pledge.
Um,
you know,
join our rod and gun club.
Bah,
a national wildlife federation.
These lands are here for everybody.
It's not just hunters and fishermen.
Um,
and Oh,
you got to do is write emails and call
your duly represent your officials that
are there to represent you.
And by the way,
back country hunters and anglers has a
form that you could fill out on their
site.
They'll send it for you,
you enter entering your email,
they have like a,
a letter that's already written up,
so it's super easy to do and they'll,
they'll direct you to where it needs to
be sent.
And you know,
they're doing a great job of setting
that up and letting people know.
I mean,
we got to be,
got to be wise about this.
This is,
we have an amazing place.
It's an,
it's an amazing thing that the fact that
you guys live,
like you were saying that,
uh,
what does it church Frank Church,
what does it,
Frank Church,
Frank Church wilderness.
I mean,
imagine if you went up there and it's
fucking mall.
Oh No.
Somebody chopped all the trees down and
we'll put up a gold cart.
So if you look at the state planned
example,
read the state lands are there to make
money for the states.
And like we said,
state gets in trouble.
They sell those lands,
fire anything,
right?
They just,
it just sucks all the money out of the
state and then the states literally
mandated not to have a negative balance
so that once that happens,
it's like,
how are we going to make our money?
How is Roosevelt so wise?
He had just panic,
fear of God put into him because he had
this realization that he's like,
oh my God,
the entire reason I am who I am today is
because I had this opportunity to go out
and chase animals and and if I saw
horizon line,
I could go over the top of it because
nobody owned it.
He was like,
that made me who I am.
I got to try to make sure that this is
here for the next person.
People don't understand that in many
countries that's not really possible and
that's actually the story of Robin Hood.
Story of Robin Hood wasn't really about
stealing from the rich and stealing
their money and giving it to the poor.
It was about hunting lands.
That was the original.
The king did not let anyone hunt in the
kingdoms hunting lands and Robin Hood
was like,
fuck you.
And he went out the air and he was
shooting deer and getting people food
because people were starving.
And that,
that is something that we can do here in
America that you can't.
It's like,
it's one of the reasons why you get so
much hate mail from Europe.
You've got a lot of hate mail from
places where they don't have
recreational hunting because to them,
and they don't even understand it and
they're eating steak,
they're eating steak.
Like my wife got into an argument with
one of her friend's husbands were,
um,
you know,
she was saying that,
uh,
I was on a hunting trip and this guy was
eating a steak,
carving a steak,
literally are at dinner.
And he's like,
well,
that's deplorable.
That's deplorable.
He hunts animals,
like,
you don't have to do that.
Like,
she.
And she's like,
you're eating a steak.
She's like,
well,
these animals are farmed animals.
And they're.
I go,
she goes,
well,
don't you think that that animal lived
to horrific existence?
And then finally was killed.
You think that's better than someone
just out of nowhere.
You're hiding behind a bush making cow
calls.
And you blast and Arrow through the
heart of some wild beast and then take
that thing down off the mountain.
You have the experience,
you have the food.
You also have this wild encounter with
this,
this magnificent beasts that you have
this connection to that every time you
eat,
like every time I eat a steak off of
that elk,
I think about the experience of hunting
that thing.
I think about seeing it.
I think about cutting it up and carrying
it out of there.
I did the whole thing about it is all
it's all connected.
That loading it into the truck,
hoisting it up.
Like the whole thing is like in my mind,
every time I cut into the meat and
people at the end of the day are
genetically hardwired to do that.
Yeah.
It's weird.
You know,
it's weird when you tap into that file
and go,
you didn't know about this file working
for it,
man.
Work Experience on public lands.
There is.
It's just.
We talk about this at length all the
time and Kenton's got this knicker
analogy and we're walking around shot
show and there's this European hunting
company down the road and he stopped me
and he's like,
Hey Kel.
It's like we lose all this land.
This is what we're going to be making
knickers fake hunting.
I'm not gonna say there's fake hunting,
but it's like a canned experience
hunting here and ones where they
released the pheasants out of the back
of a truck and that does happen folks.
There's a thing called pheasant shoots,
European pheasant shoots and they
literally release these birds and the
birds fly away and guys stand there with
guns waiting for them to release from
the cage and shoot them.
That's how Dick Cheney shot his friend.
Remember that?
Remember that story?
He shot his friend in the fucking face
and that was a canned hunt where they
just opened.
They literally open a can.
The birds fly out and they wait and boom
and shoot them.
I mean the hunting thing.
It's honestly like being outside
of your,
your comfort zone.
That is it.
Fabien and,
and I mean,
you know,
and if,
if that's not going to happen,
I don't know,
I'm not interest
did,
I don't know man,
but public hunting experiences,
man,
we're all,
you know,
that's where you follow the rules read
because everybody gets the same
experience on and on our side.
We are constantly like analyzing our
clothing and analyzing our days and
we're getting to be totally truthful
ma'am.
Life at firstline.
Pretty fricking good man.
We get to spend a lot of days in the
woods way more than your average joe
gets to and that's how we make stuff
good and
well with the way you guys do it is you
have new pieces and then you give them
to like your representatives,
like people that you guys have like w,
what do you guys call them?
Ambassadors or something like that when
you call them,
you know,
team guys,
team guys.
So you have a bunch of guys who I follow
on Instagram,
hardcore hunters who spend a giant chunk
of their life out in the woods.
Some are public,
some are not,
but the idea is to set,
to send them to people that use them in
tons of different environments like,
you know,
we hunted in a rocky so we know we've
got plenty of experience there,
but it's cool.
We'll,
we'll send stay stuff to,
you know,
guys hunting in BC or guys hunting in ak
where it's raining all the time,
but that's the,
that's the goal,
you know,
or where it's hot,
but being able to send stuff out and
have it used in these tons of different
environments allows us just to build
better stuff,
you know?
Yeah.
And it's
real trial and error thing.
Were you taking these super experienced
guys and when you said some guys are
public,
some guys are not.
What you mean is some guys have public
profiles in some guys,
they just stay under the radar and just
third guys like that,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And I mean that's it.
Everything gets thoroughly tested in the
end.
That's the fun part.
But the amazing thing about us and one
of the things that I love is we get
interns and people from all across the
country that have sometimes very little
experience and sometimes their input is
the most valuable for sure.
You get a bunch of people who are like,
I know it all right.
I,
oh no,
don't worry about that.
Nobody does that.
And then you get this girl from Ohio.
And she's like,
well what about this?
And this happened to me.
And you're like,
really?
Yeah,
no,
because it's a fresh brand new
perspective of somebody who just started
hunting.
And I think that that's been an
incredibly valuable on our line too.
So
living there too is it's living in the
mountains,
you know,
you get to take stuff from all different
sports,
whether you're,
you know,
riding your bike or whether you're back
country skiing,
like a lot of that stuff crosses over,
you know.
And I think that allows us to round
things out nicely.
Like,
you know,
hiking,
hunting is quite different than hiking,
right?
Like hiking,
people want to build the lightest thing
they can build that can do whatever.
Hunting totally different.
You're off the trail,
you're going through bushes,
like you kind of have to throw that
lightest thing out the window,
you know,
you have to approach it of like how
heavy can I actually build this and have
it still work well because it's going to
get thrashed,
you know what I mean?
So you've got to approach it from kind
of a different shift and how,
you know when you build stuff it needs
to be versatile,
right?
Like you can't have,
you know,
I don't know.
It did.
The equivalent would be like having a
guy that was a construction worker and
he's got an eight penny nail.
He's got a 16 penny nails.
He have ate penny hammer and a 16 penny
hammer.
It's like,
no,
you need to be able to do everything
with,
you know,
a certain amount of stuff because you're
going out in the woods and you know,
you might be walking slow,
you might be stopping,
you might be going uphill,
you might be going down hill,
you know,
and it just allows carrying fewer things
that do more job.
And then you might have to go through
thick brush and you might have to have
clothes that are durable or if you're in
Texas you might have stuff that has
thorns and shit.
It's going to be ripping your clothes
and don't go to Texas.
Don't go to that effort.
Everything stabs you in Texas is that.
Texas is a great example of what could
possibly happen if we lost public lands
because Texas is weird.
I love Texas.
Don't get me wrong.
I love the state.
I love the people.
It's one of my favorite places on earth,
but Texas hunting is very strange.
There's a lot of it that's high fence
and a lot of it is like over feeders.
They have like these feed machines and
these animals come to the feed machines
and they're overrun with wild pigs and
then an amputee is fucking weird.
African animals that you can hunt
anytime you want.
I mean,
there's.
It was a bit for my last special,
but it's true.
There's more tigers in captivity in
Texas than there are in all of the wild
of the world.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh,
I'm telling me that's not true.
Totally true.
There's more tigers and dudes.
Fucking backyard.
It's private collections.
Not Zeus.
Not Wildlife.
Sanctuaries.
More Tigers in private collections in
taxis will 100 percent legal.
There's no laws in Texas.
You just can't have wheat.
No wheat for your.
That's it.
No gay marriage.
No Lien.
I want to hunt in Texas,
but clean,
but yet,
but I would like to 100 there.
It's awesome.
I love Texas,
but you like they have like symitar oryx
and fucking Elan's and all these weird
African animals that are running around.
Look at that.
There are more captive tigers in Texas
than in the wild.
As real.
As real as fuck,
but yeah man,
you don't need the type of innovation.
20,000
privately owned big cats including
tigers,
lions and cougars currently living in
captivity in the US,
but the exact number is unknown due to
insufficient recordkeeping.
None of your fucking business quarter
doesn't count like those little kind of
those little whatever.
No Man.
I've been to Texas and I've,
I've,
I have a friend in Texas that has a
buddy of his that has a fucking tiger
thing and his yard,
he's got this giant fenced out.
Area's got a giant and in his ranch he's
got a bunch of fucking tigers and it'll
just feed them like a cow.
They'll live cow.
No,
well they could if you want to.
Maybe we won't admit it to me,
but they'd take a cow or calf,
shoot it in the head,
toss it over the fence.
These things tear it apart.
Unreal.
And they watch it.
Ha.
They fucking drink.
A couple of Budweiser says,
fuck their cousin and he ha.
Look at that.
Chief of Dallas and his wife are the
proud owners of three,
600 pound tigers.
They have raised since they were born,
Jesus Christ,
police chief in Dallas,
former police chief,
Jesus Christ.
Like many Texans,
Bill Rathburn is no longer satisfied
with an ordinary pit will.
I had a German shepherd,
but that queer,
all you want to do is Hump my leg.
Tired of this Nigga,
Goddamn American animal.
These cats tend to mind me even though I
use no discipline.
He says,
no discipline at all.
Shut your fucking mouth before you get
killed.
He has 22 tigers.
This guy said he's even trained these
tigers to remain team.
Oh my God.
You unfortunately you can buy at tiger
for less than a thousand dollars.
Now it makes me think tigers do new.
See,
Texas has completely different laws when
it comes to wildlife.
Wildlife in Texas is not.
It's it's private property.
It's a whole different situation.
I mean they have tags and it comes to
like white tail deer and indigenous
species,
but when it comes in,
who knows if even the white tails are
indigenous,
they're.
I mean they're bringing them in from
farms so they have bigger racks now.
They have a lot of weird shit.
They do,
it must be if you have a high fence,
then it's once you add things like fully
fenced,
everything within becomes private.
Yeah,
it must be.
I think that's exactly what it is,
but there's a lot of like eastlands and
a oryx and all these African animals and
the axis deer that have gone rogue.
They've gotten through fences and now
they're just wild and free range.
Our Dad,
what do they call them in?
In New Zealand?
Convicts.
Escapees,
escapees.
I would.
That would be crazy if a cat got loose,
it could go nuts out there.
Right?
Oh Man.
I'm sure it's happened.
I'm sure if you drive down the road
somewhere in Jasper,
Texas or something,
you see that tire.
Scariest thing in the world.
Tigers in Texas.
We don't even know how many there are.
I don't.
I.
I'm blown away right now.
I have a whole bit about it,
man.
She watched this come out of the woods.
This.
Yeah,
it's.
It's a very Texas a very odd place,
but what I wanted to highlight is like,
man,
you don't want that to be the only way
you can get a hunting experience because
Texas is,
it's fucking weird.
We weren't,
we wouldn't have jobs,
man.
I mean,
yeah.
The reason for innovation is that
competition,
that being outside,
pushing yourself,
you know,
climb,
uh,
new peaks.
Why is the hunting clothing industry
like a bunch of fucking high school
girls?
Because there's,
there's,
there's a lot of weirdness like cliques,
like if you were Sitka,
you're not supposed to wear cool.
You.
If you were cool you,
you're not supposed to wear firstly may.
I thought you were an under armour guy
sitting over there with that first
lectured on,
like what are you,
bunch of fucking girls,
high school girls.
Not that there's anything wrong with
being a girl or being in high school.
I used to be in high school and every
girl,
but I have no problem.
I'm glad you picked that to clear up,
but you know what I'm saying.
It's like fucking,
it's like a clicky little weird thing
where they're on teams.
Like,
Hey,
there's,
there's no goddamn teams.
Like I had a conversation with one of
the Sitka,
Harrison,
Jason Harrison found the,
you started out with Sitka and then he,
they,
you know,
they pushed them out and they bought it
out and I'm sick of guys in the cool.
You guys don't get along.
Like you guys are out of your fucking
minds.
This shit bro.
Staff thing.
Maybe that's where that green team
mentality,
man,
it's the same thing as people from Texas
that don't like people from Wyoming,
you know?
It's like,
uh,
you know,
we played y'all in the folk and
superbowl and kicked her.
It was really hard to believe.
I don't,
you know,
we're very friendly with.
Yeah,
you guys are you guys on.
I think it'd be real hard for me to
believe that anybody's out there being
like,
listen,
if you put this on,
you fucking hate those people.
Oh definitely.
There's people like that out there.
People kind of just pick it up and run
with it.
Yeah.
Some,
I'm sure some people are ultra
competitive and it comes from that,
like just the way it is in business,
right?
Instead of concentrating on what you're
doing,
a lot of people concentrate on the other
people that are doing what you're doing
in this.
These fuckers are trying to get us and
we need it Vogan manner,
but the competition is good.
That's the good part.
Yeah.
Right.
The competition is amazing because you
guys are constantly elevating your game.
Like I said,
Ryan,
I warrior stuff when I went to Nevada
and it was like,
man,
those fucking.
What is the,
like the corrugated.
Yeah,
the corrugated guide pants.
This fucking,
they're great man.
They're so,
like loose,
like when you're walking in them,
there's no binding at all.
They're tough and durable and I'm like,
you guys nailed it.
You nailed it on a lot of stuff.
It's a cool system in that,
you know,
generally speaking you go to a few
different shows,
like the outdoor retailer and whatever,
and you get to see all the best stuff,
right?
Like whether it be from the Albert,
Patagonia,
everything.
Um,
and you know,
you get to build the best thing you can
build and there's like,
you know,
a couple of few companies that literally
like us,
that cost is no object.
I mean it's way down the list and I,
I wish we're making things as cheap as
we can and that's still expensive,
but it's a fun thing to be able to make
the best you can make.
Right.
And some people might say,
oh,
our steps better because we,
I don't know,
whatever it is,
what it is,
but
everything is so good now.
Yeah,
it's,
it's so great.
Selfishly we can make it first selves
you so much better than when I started
hunting in 2012,
which is incredible.
And the four and a half years that I've
been hunting stuff has gotten a lot
better.
It's,
that's really interesting.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
There's an accelerated curve out there
of competition and innovation and it's
for people that don't even hunt,
like you can get your stuff in solid
colors and it is amazing outdoor where
it's as good as you're going to get.
Like I have this,
this jacket that I was wearing the day
when it's cold out and my wife was like,
what?
A ski and Jack and like firstlight joke
and pitched because it was just black.
I'm like,
this is the warmest fucking jacket.
It's so light and so thin,
but you know,
it's.
What is it?
You're puffy.
So you guys got the uncompaghre a great
jacket.
I mean it's just,
it's the perfect jacket for like when
it's Kinda cold out.
And I wore that in Montana when I was
doing on Anthony Bourdain show too.
I'm like,
it was fucking freezing out and I'm like
this Jack.
It's amazing.
It doesn't want nothing but a good time.
And Dan Bailey the pheasants forever.
Do who's good time.
And Dan bayless the way you say the
nervous with the two.
He had the two griffons,
the two pointing dogs?
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
Oh yeah.
Oh that's awesome man.
Yeah,
the bird fonting is fun,
but it's like way down on the list for
me.
Well Dude,
you're skin you.
So we were talking about elk hunting in
Idaho.
Yeah,
we're doing that.
When we doing that,
here's some time out.
Okay.
Well,
it's hard to give you some.
I've got kids.
I've got a wife.
Everybody's bitching at me.
I've heard of those things.
Yeah.
Fights those battles all the time.
You've managed to stay clean.
Ken's got restrictions right now.
Donald Trump has made your house to
swear free zone.
Is that what you were saying?
That wow,
what happened?
I to my wife might not have the same
political views.
So if we've gotten pretty uh,
uh,
was it the grab 'em by the pussy talks
that he pushed her over the top.
It did me no favors as far as having a
house that was free loose.
Do you have boys or girls?
Two boys and a girl.
Oh,
okay.
You're lucky.
Yeah.
He's just like a balance there.
Girls and two boys in your house and
then you.
Oh,
for me,
dude,
it's all chicks.
My fucking whole house overrun by
checks.
And my mom,
my wife's mom lives nearby.
She's over the,
over the fucking house too.
It's all women.
All women.
You get a lot of times women.
Yeah.
Daddy's going to go outside and pretend
he's still a man.
Fucking hide.
Sirens trying to bring you to the rocks.
It's funny though,
you know.
So what,
what laws to get established in your
household?
Oh,
I don't know,
you know,
it just,
uh,
we just have to be concerned with what,
what,
what we say doesn't,
isn't it negative?
How did Donald Trump bring this about?
I don't know.
I think,
like you said,
I think there was enough.
Like,
you know,
I have two boys,
right?
So they're not afraid to call each other
a pussy if some things go.
You know what I mean?
They heard on the news.
Yeah,
no,
but they're,
you know,
they're into their extreme sporty and
they're skiers mountain bikers.
Then,
you know,
inevitably it's like,
there's the jump built or something and
first thing like it's called,
as,
you know,
the p right?
Pass them
out.
Plan.
That was the first thing.
I was like,
no,
you're a Dick Dick,
do you like that?
And I was like,
whoa.
She's serious.
Like she did not.
That was not going to be a derogatory
term and that's fine.
Whatever it shouldn't be,
but you know,
it was funny because you know,
they'll heckle each other and you know,
they're boys.
They all,
they want to get after some nasty
gnarly.
Yes.
You know,
jump or whatever on their bikes and
somebody's got a Guinea pig it and sure
enough it's probably the one that got
called a pussy first.
Right.
So we don't do well for my,
for me,
when Donald Trump,
the whole story came out.
It was great because then all of a
sudden everybody,
so many people are saying pussy and it
seems like this country's like backing.
We had gotten some weird politically
correct phase just in the last couple of
years where people are so mad at so many
different.
Different groups are so mad at the way
our culture is that there was all these
words you weren't allowed to say anymore
and there was all these new things like
you're not allowed to wear sombreros
because it's cultural appropriation.
They were getting mad at people for
cooking other cultures,
dishes,
like people got so politically correct
that like the good thing about Donald
trump being in office is that I said
that political correctness is just took
a missile to the Deq because like that
guy as the fucking commander in chief
man,
that political correctness shit,
it's like,
it doesn't seem very effective.
It didn't work here.
Like you can't,
you can't and people are fighting and of
course in rallying and protesting and
all that jazz.
But it.
The good thing about,
it's like you realize like,
oh,
that's just a word like pussies.
Just a word.
Like in that guy was saying pussy,
now he's the president.
Like it's not really like this is like
taboo word that summons demons,
you know,
it's,
it's just a word and its intent.
That's important.
It's not demonizing words and making
these words impossible to say because
we've made them like,
there's certain words now that you just
can't say in our culture or people get
upset at you that were real common.
Like retard.
He calls someone to retard.
You're not saying someone has a disease.
You know,
you're,
you're saying someone's a fucking
knucklehead,
all the cars retarded.
You,
you know the intent of that word,
but people are saying,
no,
don't say that anymore.
That's offensive will.
The more you create offensive words and
the more you create words that are not
there,
you're not allowed to say them.
The more you get to give those words
power and people are going to,
they can't wait to se them.
They can't.
Then those words become like nuclear
nuclear option.
Then you've got something right.
You've got the c word,
you know it's,
you're always holding onto that one for
chickens.
Crazy.
You know,
like listen,
like that.
It's impossible to come back from.
There's not an equivalent word for men
like bike telling us.
We can't say that word.
You can call it dicks all day long.
You fucking Dick App guilty as charged
on tv now practically that you can.
It's as long as it's not like a,
you know,
I mean I think like NBC,
CBS,
they still don't use it,
but like any cable show they use that.
Now.
All I know is Kenton's wife tends to
look at me like that is the source of
looseness right there.
That's single man with a mustache.
This man got cut loose to spend too much
time with him.
It could all go down.
Uh,
just go feral.
Yeah.
What's,
why.
Like no one tells Ryan were to go.
Ryan can just go into the woods anytime
he wants.
I don't think that's right.
Yeah.
What about he doesn't have a leash on
how many times did he call and check was
just out there with no leash collar.
I get a long leash.
I get along,
especially during hunting season,
but mark might still elite.
You have a leash.
Brian doesn't have elite.
She's just asked him.
He doesn't have to call anybody.
He just goes where he wants it is what
it is.
But if he just decides to take that
mustache and go for a hike,
nobody can tell them that.
That,
that pisses women off because then then
demand goes,
yeah.
Hey,
Ryan says healthy with no leash still
whenever he wants.
I wish I was like that.
Like I love being married.
I love having kids.
I love the whole day.
I love having a family,
but I got a buddy,
my friend,
Ari.
You know what already did?
He just went off the grid,
shut his fucking phone off.
He won't answer his emails.
He just disappeared.
He went to Pacific.
Just want to do it for a few months.
He's a.
he's a stand up comic.
Hilarious guy.
Successful show on comedy central is
doing great.
Kicking ass.
He just decided,
you know what?
I need some experiences in my life to
write about,
to talk about,
so I'm just going to fucking stop
talking to people and disappear for a
few months ago.
I talked to him in two months.
I haven't talked to him.
I don't know where the fuck is.
You call his voicemail.
It just says the subscriber you have
reached to shut off incoming call.
That's amazing,
dude.
This thing is just the most devious
creation on the planet earth.
It is.
It is
scribers request.
This phone does not accept incoming
calls.
Message and V,
one
rockin message.
.
It doesn't give a fuck if my wife heard
that.
Well,
he's out there.
You think that's good?
He's got no one to call in to check in,
but he can check in and do whatever he
wants,
but he wants everything cool.
Yeah.
Right.
Late.
She can call me up.
Hey,
faggot.
I'm still alive and then hang up the
phone.
That's it.
I'm like,
God,
listen.
Yeah.
The ability to checkout.
We can.
I mean where we are,
it is narrow valley public land
everywhere.
As soon as you get off the valley floor,
you're on public land like we talked
about.
I can hate.
I can hate to the fricking Yukon,
man.
That's crazy and you can be disconnected
as disconnected as you want to be and
there is no price tag on that.
That and I need.
Well that's the constant dilemma amongst
a lot of hunters,
especially the really hardcore guys.
A lot of the podcast that I listened to
like a bunch of them,
but the big dilemma is how much time
does your family allow you to get out?
How much?
How much time can you spend?
Can you do one of those 30 day trips?
You know,
like there's a lot of guys that do like
a 30 day trip that's pretty heavy.
That's a heavy as fuck,
but there's some street cred to that or
should I say trail cred.
Right,
right.
Like,
you know,
I'm fucking Raylynn said to me once,
it was really funny,
man.
We were laughing.
We were talking about grizzly man.
We're talking about the Werner Herzog
documentary and Rinella was.
He goes,
I'll tell you what though.
that guy did some fucking hard camping.
He goes,
I got to respect that guy.
That guy was a hard camper coming from
things the hard way it no one loves the
way more than Manila.
He loves it.
Yeah,
he does.
but there's something to be said for it
because just like we were talking about,
you know,
things get more pc or whatever.
It's you start patting yourself and all
of a sudden you don't know what rough
is.
Safe spaces.
NERF,
the hard edges of the world.
It's super important that we'd be
totally inclusive.
Competition is not a bad thing and
there's no more primal competition than
you trying to go out and get your own
food that's running around trying to
stay alive and what do you have?
You got a pointy stick.
You're trying to shoot another
concession.
Every time a hunter goes into the woods,
something dies.
That's what I.
that's what I hear all the time.
It's like,
well,
I saw five people go into the woods
behind my house on a public easement.
I was at a city council meeting
listening to this Gal talk somebody
public easement so people can access
public land.
Only way their housing development got
built was so that because they allowed
to easements so people could get to the
public land.
She's saying that five people went past
her house and five elk died.
It's like not the case.
I'll tell you right now.
It's never happened.
I don't punch my tag until the absolute
last day because as soon as I clip it,
I gotta be back into work.
Yeah,
I mean I've had conversations with
people that don't understand the like,
you know,
you go out there and you shoot these
animals.
I go,
no,
you go out there and you try to get an
animal.
She's like,
well how often are you successful?
I said,
well,
I went on 500 slabs and I'm super
dedicated practice constantly.
I'm absorbed in it.
Five hundred,
three of them aren't successful,
so that's.
And that's a good,
that's a good average.
So you're spending 15,
you know,
like each,
each hunt at least five days out in the
woods and just nothing.
Sorry,
come back home mouth and struck out and
go,
oh,
that was an absolute failure.
My kids looking at me like such a loser.
Nothing like nothing struck out like you
didn't,
nothing,
nothing.
You little.
Yeah.
Figure that out.
That car company can come with me one
day.
Right now you're too little to hike.
Kyla,
what are the ages?
Six and eight are getting close.
They love.
They eat everything though,
man.
They've eaten bear elk.
The elk all the time.
Maybe they've been eating wild game
since they were little.
They know they don't know the
difference.
They like it.
They're both scanning.
Scan since they were two nice.
I took them when they're just so little
that they just pizza down the window.
They had the little connector with the
two skis and they just slide.
My name is Rosie.
I don't even think she was too.
You have a rosy?
Yeah,
no way.
No Way.
Oh No.
Well,
because Steve Daughter at.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Kids are,
you know,
it's an amazing thing to have a little
person that you're raising and you get
to see them learning things for the
first time,
which will never happen again.
You know,
everything they learned for the first
time,
like every,
the first time they went skiing.
I remember the this look on their face
like we've got the mittens on like this
is crazy.
I've got a helmet on.
Whether they're so happy and excited
like there's never gonna be a first like
that again.
And the more first you can have in this
life,
I think the better and more rich your
life will be.
The more experiences,
the more times you can learn thing and
people get locked into these patterns in
their life and I don't know why it
happens and I don't know what causes it,
but we get a job and we get a career and
we get a path and a neighborhood and
that's boom,
and then the first stop,
there's no more firsts and then it
becomes the same shit over and over
again in life becomes mundane and life
becomes tired and grow old in a lot of
ways other than aging,
but the other thing that happens is you
realize that this is what's going on and
then you seek novelty.
You seek new experiences and hopefully
that's what happens to more people more.
When they listened to podcasts like this
and they,
they,
they hear you guys talk about your
experiences and they said,
God damn it.
I need some of that in my life.
You know,
I need.
I need to just go fucking camp.
I need to just go out there.
I need to wake up and hear bulls bugling
and I need to wake up and hear birds
that I don't recognize Turpin and
squawking and look over the ridge and
see a bear.
I'm like,
whoa.
The fuck is that.
That's a wild bear.
It's just hanging out,
chilling,
being,
doing bare stuff like all that stuff is
like having new experiences like that.
It's just giant for your life and again,
if you're not in a hunting,
you don't even want to go try archery.
Just try that.
Just a new experience.
Call somewhere,
find a place that gives lessons.
Oh,
just go drive out the national park,
drive out to bears ears national
monument.
Check some things out.
That road trip car camping is fantastic.
Are to get people out of their comfort
zone.
Part might be steps,
man.
Go do it.
Get out there.
One of the most fulfilling things I do,
I try to do.
Take somebody out on their first time
every year and it is one of the most
fulfilling things I do every year.
I'm sure it's just the best.
Well,
it always blows somebody's mind.
I mean all you have to do is hear a
vehicle and people are just like,
whoa.
Yeah,
I mean it doesn't sound like a real
animal.
Jamie.
Queue up some elk bugle because for
people who've never heard it before,
they don't know what the fuck we're
talking about.
You live in a city somewhere,
you poor bastard.
It sounds like an animal from the Lord
of the rings.
It doesn't sound like a real thing.
It sounds like some crazy exotic bees.
Is that a good one?
Heard a little bit of it.
Did you just pick the first one you
found?
Now that's not even like a crazy one
that's like,
that sounds like a little bitch bull.
But this is a 1000 pound forest horse
that's making me.
That's a real bull right there,
baby.
That guy is like,
I get all the pussy.
No,
look at him screaming and then they
throw their head back and just launched
that in the end.
So these guys are going back
fourth in this video.
What a crazy animal.
It is.
Not something you get sick of hearing.
Never met every time I've been elk
hunting and I've been elk hunting a few
times now you see one and you hear it
and just your whole body like tingles.
It's like,
Whoa,
what a magical experience to just be
around those things,
to feel bad,
to feel that noise in your chest.
Jesus to the size of that fucker.
Yeah.
God,
I mean the things that are keeping those
things alive or the money that comes
from hunting,
that's super important for people to
recognize.
There was a time in this country with
those things were almost extinct in the
early 19 hundreds.
There was very few.
There's very few deer.
There's very few anything and now
there's more deer in this country than
the war.
When Columbus didn't discover this place
and that's why people are so passionate
about this man.
Look at the history like we've landed.
We said,
hey,
this place is going to be different than
where we came from.
The land or the animals belong to the
people.
We fucked that up real quick with market
hunting.
Yeah.
Market hunting is an interesting thing
that most people don't.
Didn't even know that that was a real
thing.
They know that we kill off all the
buffalo,
but they don't really understand that
back in the day before refrigerators and
you got to get meat like pretty much
then.
Yes,
a man read Michener's chesapeake,
that there's a great description on
market hunting in the Chesapeake Bay.
Guys going out with a low profile boats
with cannons on them,
stuffing them full of shards and nails
and stuff,
and they'd go up to these big rafts they
called when ducks and geese sleep in the
middle of the night on big bodies of
water.
They all get huddled up together and the
on this is in the Chesapeake Bay,
but it happened in the Great Lakes.
Also big rafts of birds.
And uh,
you would,
you know,
push off in the middle of the night,
sneak up really slowly on these big
rafts of sleeping birds and touch this
cannon off.
Shoot this cannon.
And then,
and that's how the Chesapeake Bay
retriever was a basically bred into
existence was they needed a big hearty
dog that could withstand cold water.
This dog would spend hours never getting
back in the boat,
but just constantly retrieving for hours
because they'd
shoot,
you know,
and probably a mouthful of nails,
200 birds.
Right.
And then that dog had to then sit on the
pile at birds and defend it the next
day.
Everybody else.
Right.
Because those burgers are worth money.
So they were taking them across to a.
So they had to be guide dogs or guard
dogs rather.
And they also had to be retrievers.
Yes.
Whoa.
Yeah.
And then they would bring those to
market by the barrel full and that's an.
They were only good for a couple of
days.
Yeah.
People would,
you know,
they would try to keep them cool.
And then people try to buy them as quick
as they could before they spoiled and
then you have to go right back out and
do it again.
In that process resulted in just a
devastation on the wildlife in this
country.
Yes.
And the same thing was happening with
white tail deer,
elk,
black bears,
everything.
Nice.
And obviously,
obviously,
yeah,
that's the one that everybody harps on,
but they don't realize that it was
pretty much everything
we could eat they shot and that's what
we can put a price tag on it.
Right?
And that's one of the major issues that
we're seeing in Idaho is they want to,
and with some of this auction tag stuff
is we're starting to put a dollar amount
on our game.
And what do you mean by auction tax
where we're pulling to eggs out of the
general pool.
So like right now,
um,
let's say in the state,
Idaho,
um,
uh,
we could all put in,
you know,
a thousand people put in for a,
for elk tags in a prime unit,
the unit that grows the biggest balls,
well,
in order to raise more funds,
they started to remove one of those tags
and auction them off.
So that's putting a,
you know,
whatever we could all put in for $30 for
the remaining three elk.
But if we choose to,
we can all try to bid on each other for
that fourth tag.
So if there is a limited amount of tags,
people have to realize that your chances
of drawing that tag are probably pretty
slim,
unless you build up points every year,
you build up a certain amount of points
in that makes it more likely that you're
going to draw a tag.
So people that don't understand the
process,
so one person,
they'll take one tag and they put it off
and they'll allow it to be auctioned off
and sometimes they'll go for hundreds of
thousands of dollars,
right?
Like crazy rich dudes.
So there's two schools of thought.
One School of thought is look how much
money he's going to conservation because
this one rich asshole that wants to
spend $400,000
to kill a bighorn sheep.
Yes.
And I think saying it like you do the
rich asshole thing.
That's how everybody says it,
right?
And of course I get really frustrated
with that because I'm like,
well,
aren't we as the remaining sportsmen in
this pool supporting the rich asshole by
giving him the ability?
Why don't the thousand people in the
pool just agree to spend a couple extra
bucks on the tag?
Well
that might help,
but is it really going to get you the
hundreds of thousands of dollars?
So that one tag,
I mean,
it seems like without burdening the
regular sportsmen who doesn't want spend
like didn't
Montana like significantly raised their
tags,
the pricer tags recently?
There was a lot of complaints.
Yeah,
they're a.
But they put a lot of burden on the out
of state hunter,
not the instate.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
The resident hunter gets a break,
right?
They get our instate.
Um,
you know,
I,
I'm,
I supported a tag fee increase for
resident hunters because we haven't had
one in a lot of years.
So what's a tag like an over the counter
tag for elk right now in Montana,
or excuse me,
in Idaho,
I want to save 40 bucks.
Thirty five bucks.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
and I want to say Montana 17 as a
resident,
she knew how amazing it is there.
For 17 bucks you can get 500 pounds of
meat and most honestly your effort to.
Most hunters,
I mean speaking for the guys that I hang
around with and nobody else.
We like to drink our beer.
What?
Yes.
Well,
and spending $17 on a case of beer that
has gone all generously say a couple of
weeks.
Right.
I love,
I love to hunt elk and deer.
Absolutely love it.
It is.
I mean it's just something that I look
forward to the year long,
right.
I can bury more than willing to spend
more than 17 bucks on,
on the potential.
The thrill of the excuse to go hunt for
sure.
Yeah.
I think that's reasonable and that will
pretty much within anybody's budget.
I mean just raise it to 20 bucks and
then all that money is going to go back
to the state and it's going to help and
it's still very,
very,
very reasonable.
Collectively say,
I mean it reasonably don't know the
exact price generally because you can
buy a sportsman's package.
So I think it's 100 and I don't know,
$5.
You can hunt and fish,
like basically anything that's not a
draw everything over the counter as long
as you don't go over the limit of what
you could get.
Pretty much,
I mean pretty amazing.
Yeah.
And Idaho's a true lottery.
Right?
So there are no points.
Oh,
it's one of those dates.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
And I truly like because it spreads out
the pressure.
So our draw odds are fantastic.
So now we're where someone wants to
auction those things off,
like what is a,
like one of those crazy elk tag because
I know that wild sheep is the big one,
right?
Like bighorn sheep are the ones that
people spend it for three.
Oh five.
Is that what it was?
Three hundred and $5,000.
And at the same an elk tag a sheep while
for shakes,
Syria that,
um,
that we hunted that I think last year
went for over half a million,
but you've got to keep in sheep.
Sheep are the rarest thing that we have,
like they're doing really well in the
areas that they're doing well in.
But then the brakes,
we saw a ton of them.
It's crazy everywhere,
but disease,
you know,
they're super susceptible to disease,
domestic sheep diseases.
Correct.
Because there was a sitcom of video,
uh,
that they did.
They did those short film about the,
uh,
door
I heard is,
how do you say it?
T e n d e r o y,
yeah,
tenderloin.
And these sheep are suffering from
diseases that are coming from domestic
sheep.
So they're trying to figure out a way to
breed a domestic sheep that doesn't
catch this disease so that they can
reintroduce healthy sheep into these
areas and not have them be infected by
these different diseases.
They get some really fascinating stuff.
Do you remember a kit?
Fischer was on that hunt with us,
um,
in the breaks,
he was Rowan,
one of the boats,
um,
he works for National Wildlife
Federation and that's when he does is he
does conflict mitigation basically.
So he identifies those,
a grazing allotments and most women are
on public land.
Um,
and he identifies the conflict or
grazing allotments mostly for bighorn
sheep that could put domestic sheep that
could potentially be carrying diseases
in contact with these wild cheaper.
And so he's looking to,
you know,
typically pay the rancher that has that
grazing allotment fair market value for
that grazing allotment and he just turns
it back over to uh,
the US forest service.
And that's a real issue with buffalo,
right,
with wild bison because there's two
schools of thought and there's one
school,
it's about Brucellosis and that
brucellosis will somehow or another be
transmitted from the bison to cattle.
Um,
but apparently a lot of people say that
that's kind of a bullshit argument
because it's really about the bison
eating up all the grazing land and
forcing out the domestic cattle.
So they using the brucellosis as an
excuse to say that this is the reason
why we need to kill off the bias and get
them out of the way.
I think there's some legitimate little
bit of on both sides.
Yeah.
And,
and the difference between the sheep and
the sheep don't carry a disease.
Bison definitely do carry,
uh,
the brucellosis.
But domestic sheep do carry.
Some domestic sheep do.
But the wild ones,
the wild wild ones don't.
But they can catch domestic sheep and
they have no,
they can't find the immune systems.
So.
But yeah,
the Bison one is,
you know,
I got a big eastern Montana family.
It takes a lot of ground to grow beef
out there.
And if that's your livelihood,
absolutely,
you know,
putting more animals on the countryside
and some fucking hulk bison thing way
bigger than a cat man.
It's going to directly impact your
livelihood.
But I think just as we were talking
about earlier,
man,
there's some,
there's some happy medium there and if,
especially if we're looking at,
you know,
um,
some of this oil and gas stuff that's
getting scary right now,
like especially with like all of a
sudden we're saying that you don't have
to clean up after yourself after he had,
you know,
started a big mind somewhere,
right?
Like I would much rather have bison out
than
like let's raise funds through sports
minor recreational than digging a big
pit in a beautiful spot.
So I don't know if that's going to cover
it though to play with the Dakota
pipeline liquid they're talking about
there.
It's just like the amount of money
that's going to come from that is just
staggering.
And so the amount of pressure that's
involved in making something like that
go through is also pretty staggering.
It is,
but it's dangerous,
you know,
and what the disaster that could take
place is you can't put a price on it
because what,
what,
what could be done if they ruin a river
system,
if somehow or another this gas line
breaks and you have oil flooding a river
system the same way they had that bp oil
rig disaster out in the Gulf.
God,
could you imagine that?
Still dealing with them,
right?
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
And how about the people that had to
deal with it?
There were living near there that were
sick,
you know,
there's all sorts of diseases and
there's all sorts of lawsuits going on
and all the cleanup crews.
I mean they had,
they made prisoners clean up the
fucking,
the BP mass and there's a lot of weird
shit involved in that,
right?
It,
uh,
I'm truly not educated on the economics
of it and my,
you know,
my brain says that no,
there's,
you know,
we couldn't,
there was no warm fuzzy eco,
you know,
lodge that we could set up that would
match the funds from,
you know,
oil and gas.
But yeah,
man,
yeah,
I'm just trying to think longterm and
boy,
it just wrecked that landscape and the
landscape is what I've been in love with
since a little kid.
So yeah,
you know,
then nobody wants to be able to let your
toilet water on fire either.
You ever see those fucking gasland
documentary is coming right out of the
tap and they guys sticks a lighter to it
and was fucking water's on fire and
people are both labeled supplementing
what we'll do.
That's always been the case.
Not with these fucking people,
but these fucking people is directly
related to fracking.
Like just all these apologists for that
stuff.
It's like how many fucking earthquakes
needed to have an Oklahoma before you
go,
hey,
um,
is this okay?
Like,
what do he doesn't have a thousand
earthquakes a year now?
Is that cool?
Like,
yeah,
as long as it's under a thousand,
we're looking at as long as we only like
pollute like three or four wells a year.
It's like survivors.
It's fine.
We got plenty of bottled water,
but it's constantly evolving thing.
Technology all across the board is
getting way,
way,
way better.
We know way more about these migration
routes and we used to,
we know way intact migration routes are
what we need for healthy mule deer.
Elk.
Um,
yeah.
That's like a recent thing they realized
how far mule deer travel,
right?
It kind of blew these biologists.
So wind blowing.
Yeah.
Hundreds of miles.
We have a deer in our unit that migrate
170 miles.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Wow.
They have to.
I mean like years like this,
we've got,
you know,
right now we've got,
I don't know,
six,
seven,
eight feet of snow on the ground.
Right.
If they don't
travel,
it's their curtains.
But when you come here and you see no
snow but so many people,
what's better regarding,
I don't know what's better.
No snow and a massive swarm of humans or
eight feet of snow.
Not that many humans.
What do you guys,
because you guys stay where you're at
and I stay where I'm at,
like a trick question because I always
want to talk to people that come from a
place like catch them and you come to
Los Angeles and see the fucking swarmed
the high,
the get on that four or five and go,
what in the fuck is this thing?
Dude,
I,
I'm not gonna.
When we hopped on the bus,
just go get a rental car.
Last night I was gripped.
It felt like I was at a Nascar race car.
Oh yeah.
They're aggressive.
You have to be.
Yeah.
They did a study that showed there's a
direct correlation between the amount of
footsteps people take per minute and the
population that they're in and also the
faster they talk they.
If the population is higher,
they will say their syllables faster.
That will say words faster.
They'll say more words in a minute.
Well,
I was a direct correlation from New
York.
Definitely talk faster.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah,
but it's fascinating.
They walk faster to here it goes.
Senator,
what is this?
Amy?
Clears way for finishing Dakota.
Oh army.
I'll work amy finishing Dakota access
oil pipeline by granting easement
opponents likely to appeal.
Oh,
just now.
Um,
but yeah,
you know,
where,
where you guys live.
It's just a completely different kind of
place.
Look at the first quote.
Go back to that.
You should mention that Obama were
approved.
This project,
the pros play.
So the loop towards.
Can't blame trump.
Fuck face lip tards.
Oh that is one of the best words.
It's come out of this whole fucking
right versus left.
Oh Man.
I mean,
like I said,
I'm just speaking off the cuff.
They're like,
you know,
I love,
I'm an outside guy.
I don't want that stuff to ever change.
But I realized there's got to be
something for everybody to.
I mean we're a big country.
It's more than just me and like super
out of the way place.
So I don't ever want to live in New York
City,
but I know a lot of people will fuck in.
Love it and good God.
Yeah.
Good luck with it.
But it's interesting when I see guys
like you that come from Idaho and then
come down here to Los Angeles and I see,
look in your face,
you're like,
fuck this place.
You can't wait to get out of here.
I live here.
I'm raising a family.
Here is where I do my work.
And you guys are like,
fuck this place.
It's just interesting.
It's like the driving.
I don't know.
Cow.
I like ran a stoplight already.
I like,
I don't know if it gets to you too lazy.
It's crazy feel.
That means to the next guy.
It's like when you put your blinker on
to change lanes,
that means here.
It means they close that space.
You don't want that fucker in.
It's going to slow me down by one 10th
of a second.
All adds up,
combat it.
It all adds up.
It's very intense.
Gentlemen,
just been a fun conversation and I hope
we illuminated a lot of these issues
with people and fuck her six slash 22
years.
Any bills like it.
And we need to do the same thing.
We did two,
six,
21.
We need to do that to 6:22
and contact that guy and start the whole
campaign all over again because you just
can't remove the resources that are
going to protect those,
those lands.
They're going to keep coming.
Very important.
So thank you guys for what you do.
And your website is firstlight.com
l I t e first firstlight hunting.com
or first light,
first light.com.
Firstlight.com.
One word.
And uh,
anything else?
Thank you buddy.
Good.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Yeah.
Bye everybody.
See you.